I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。
Hello. Hi there. Office, ladies. Hello. Hi there. Are you ready for a very fun episode today and very controversial? Oh, we got a lot of mail. So much mail. Everyone, it's customer loyalty.
你好。嗨。办公室，辣妈。你好。嗨。你们准备好迎接今天这一集非常有趣且非常有争议的节目了吗？哦，我们收到了很多信件。有这么多的信件。大家，这一集是“客户忠诚度”。
It is season nine, episode 12, written by Jonathan Green and Gabe Miller and directed by Kelly Cantley. Now, before you get into a summary, I thought we needed a little something from the episode by Jonathan Green and Gabe Miller, and directed by Kelly Cantley. Now before you get into a summary, I thought we needed a little something from the episode to kick us off. Oh, all right. Ready? Yeah.
这是第九季第十二集，由乔纳森·格林和加布·米勒编剧，凯莉·坎特利执导。现在，在你进入剧情总结之前，我觉得我们需要这一集里的一些内容来拉开序幕。哦，好吧。准备好了吗？准备好了。
Yes, we will be delivering a shipment of paper today, but I will also be delivering you a big shipment of fun. Fun. Are we gonna be delivering people a shipment of fun. Are we going to be delivering people a shipment of fun? A big shipment of fun. That's right. You heard it from Dwight. Buckle in because we've got a lot of fun stuff today. I liked that, Ange.
是的，我们今天将配送一纸箱的纸张，但我也将为你配送一大箱的欢乐。欢乐。我们要给人们配送一箱欢乐吗？我们要给人们配送一箱欢乐吗？一大箱欢乐。没错了。你从德怀特那里听到的。系好安全带，因为我们今天有很多有趣的内容。我喜欢这个，安吉。
I just thought it was fun. I love when you get a kickoff idea. It's a big shipment of fun. Come on. All right, well, here's your big summary. An important meeting in Philly prevents Jim from attending Cece's dance recital. Dwight goes to great lengths
我只是觉得很有趣。我喜欢你想到开场点子的时候。这是一大箱欢乐。来吧。好吧，这是你的重磅剧情总结。费城的一个重要会议导致吉姆无法参加西西的舞蹈汇报演出。德怀特竭尽全力
to keep Daryl at Dunder Mifflin. Nellie fears she will fall out of good standing with Andy after pairing Aaron and Pete on a project, and they get real flirty. Yeah, they do. Finally, Pam receives some good news, but her excitement is dampened by a conflict with Jim. Conflict?
把达里尔留在邓德米夫林。内莉担心在把阿伦和皮特分到一个项目后，自己会失宠于安迪，而他们两个调情得厉害。没错，他们确实有。最后，帕姆收到了一些好消息，但她的兴奋却因与吉姆的冲突而大打折扣。冲突？
Boy, is it dampened. It's a big old fight is what it is. It is. And like I said, we got some fan soapbox mail about this episode, but it is not the scene you think it is. Okay. It took me by surprise. Don't tell me.
天哪，何止大打折扣。实际上是一场好大的一场架。确实。就像我说的，我们收到了一些关于这一集的粉丝抱不平的信，但它并不是你想象的那样。好吧。这让我大吃一惊。别告诉我。
People had feelings. I mean, I want you to tell me, like when it happens. Later, okay. Let's get into fast fact number one. I'm very excited about this fast fact. We have a major guest star alert in this episode. Your daughter, Isabelle, was one of the dancers. about this fast fact we have a major guest star alert in this episode your daughter Isabelle was one of the dancers she was a ladybug and I remember it so
大家都有想法。我是说，我想让你告诉我，比如它发生的时候。待会儿，好吧。让我们进入第一条快速事实。我对这个快速事实非常兴奋。我们在这一集里有一个重量级客串明星警报。你的女儿伊莎贝尔是舞者之一。关于这个快速事实，我们在这一集里有一个重量级客串明星警报，你的女儿伊莎贝尔是舞者之一，她扮成了一只瓢虫，我记得非常
clearly oh I had so much fun first of all rewatching this rewatching it with her then I went into my digital clutter and I found videos of the rehearsal day. It was so cute. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Well, Steve Burr just reminded me that Greg's daughter, Maya, was also in this episode and it was her dance class that was featured. And then you folded Isabelle in as well.
清楚，哦，我玩得太开心了，首先是重温这一集，和她一起重温，然后我翻看我的数字杂物，找到了排练当天的视频。太可爱了。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。史蒂夫·伯格刚刚提醒我，格雷格的女儿玛雅也在这一集中，而且出镜的是她的舞蹈班。然后你也把伊莎贝尔带上了。
Yes. Well, Isabelle and Maya are a year apart and they're really close. You know those cousins you grow up with that you are a year apart and they're really close. You know those cousins you grow up with that you're close in age and they're just so much fun? So they have that kind of relationship. They're still just two peas in a pod.
对。嗯，伊莎贝尔和玛雅只差一岁，她们非常亲密。你知道那些和你一起长大的表亲吗？你们年龄相仿，她们非常亲密。你知道那些和你一起长大的表亲吗？你们年龄相近，而且她们带给你那么多快乐？所以她们有那种关系。她们俩依然像两颗豌豆一样形影不离。
In fact, today their schools are playing softball against each other and they're both on rival softball teams. Oh my goodness. I know. So I'm like, oh my gosh, the whole family is going to be there. Isabel's like, mom, we better win. So it's a very sweet friendship that they have and they were so cute when they were little.
事实上，今天她们的学校在进行垒球比赛，她们在对立的垒球队伍里。哦，天哪。我知道。所以我就想，哦，天哪，全家人都会去现场。伊莎贝尔说，妈妈，我们最好能赢。所以她们拥有非常甜美的友谊，小时候她们太可爱了。
And this is a really special memory for our family that they both got to do this. And I thought maybe I should ask Isabel what she remembered from this day. Now she was only about four years old. She's so tiny, but here's what she had to say. Hey, office ladies listeners. I am here with my daughter, Isabelle. Hi. And she's gonna talk about her time being a ladybug.
这对我们家来说是一个非常特别的回忆，她们两个都参与了。我想也许我应该问问伊莎贝尔她对这一天有什么记忆。当时她只有四岁左右。她那么小，但她是这么说的。嘿，办公室辣妈的听众们。我和我的女儿伊莎贝尔在一起。嗨。她要讲讲她当瓢虫的经历。
Yay. In this episode. All right, is we normally ask our guests, how'd you get your job on the office? But I think we can skip that one. Yeah. What do you remember? You were so little.
耶。在这集里。好吧，伊莎贝尔，我们通常会问嘉宾，你是怎么得到《办公室》的工作的？但我想我们可以跳过这个。好吧。你还记得什么？你当时太小了。
Oh, well, obviously I don't remember a lot, but I do remember being so excited to get to wear the costume. The little tutu was so cute. Oh yeah, you were in a big tutu phase then. I love tutus. Still am. And I love to be able to hang out with my cousin Maya. We got to do it together, which was so fun. Yeah. Oh, and hair and makeup. I thought that was so cool. Oh yeah, the ladies were so sweet, you guys.
哦，好吧，显然我不记得太多了，但我确实记得能穿上那套服装让我感到非常兴奋。那件小芭蕾短裙太可爱了。哦，是的，你当时正处于狂热的芭蕾短裙阶段。我喜欢芭蕾短裙。现在依然喜欢。而且我很喜欢能和我的表姐玛雅一起玩。我们一起做这件事，太有趣了。哦，还有发型和化妆。我觉得那太酷了。哦，对，女士们太温柔了，大家。
They were the best. They were so sweet. They made us feel so special. I loved it. And they let you have lip gloss. Oh my gosh. I remember you were very- I was probably so excited.
她们是最好的。她们太温柔了。她们让我们觉得自己好特别。我很喜欢。她们还让你涂了唇彩。哦，天哪。我记得你非常——我当时可能兴奋极了。
You were so excited. All right, anything else? Not that I can remember. I do remember after the dance you were tired. Oh, I probably was. I probably wanted to nap. Yep. Oh my gosh.
你太兴奋了。好了，还有别的吗？记不太清了。我只记得跳完舞后你很累。哦，我可能确实很累。我可能想小睡一觉。是的。哦，天哪。
I'm just smiling so big. You know, Isabel is my goddaughter. I know. So this was so sweet, Ann. I found so many cute photos and then something I was really surprised by that I'd forgotten about way buried in my digital clutter. One of the moms from the dance class filmed the dance rehearsal day. So we had a rehearsal day, it was on Tuesday and we filmed this on the Wednesday.
我笑得合不拢嘴。你知道的，伊莎贝尔是我的教女。我知道。所以这太甜蜜了，安吉。我找到了好多可爱的照片，然后有一件让我非常惊讶的事，我都忘了，它深深地埋在我的数字杂物里。舞蹈班的一位妈妈拍摄了舞蹈排练的那天。所以我们有一个排练日，是在星期二，我们是在星期三拍摄的。
And Isabel came to work and it was so cute because she thought, well, I'm visiting my mom at work. My mom's part of the dance too. Oh, yeah. And she kept wanting me to come stand by her and like learn the dance with her. And it's all on video and it's so precious, Jenna. And I'm so thankful for this rewatch podcast because I found this video buried way deep in email that I had forgotten about.
伊莎贝尔来上班了，太可爱了，因为她觉得，哦，我是来上班探我妈妈的班。我妈妈也参与了舞蹈。哦，是的。她一直想让我过去站在她旁边，和她一起学跳舞。这一切都在视频里，太珍贵了，珍娜。我太感激这个重温播客了，因为我找到了这个深埋在电子邮件里、我早已忘得精光的视频。
Yeah. I'm going to put part of it in stories, because it's just the cutest little girls learning this dance and me in the middle of them. Well, I loved that. And I have really cute photos from Hair and Makeup. And then the other thing the little girls were so excited about is I found photos.
是的。我打算把其中的一部分发到快拍里，因为这实在是太可爱的几个小女孩在学跳舞，而我夹在她们中间。我很喜欢这个。我还有来自发型和化妆间的超级可爱的照片。然后还有一件事让小女孩们非常兴奋，那就是我找到了照片。
You know how when we would go from our main sound stage maybe over to like the other sound stage? Sure. Well, rather than having all these little girls walk all that way from hair and makeup to that other soundstage, this is just in a parking lot, you guys. It's very safe. They let them ride in the big passenger van
你知道当我们从主摄影棚走到另一个摄影棚的时候吗？当然。好吧，与其让这些小女孩们从发型化妆间一路走到那个摄影棚，大家注意，这其实是在停车场。非常安全。她们让她们坐上了大型客运货车
and they buckled them all in, but they are so tickled. You should see this photo of their faces. They're so delighted to go like just a few hundred feet in this passenger van. Oh, oh my goodness. I'm so glad. Isabel, thank you for sharing your memories. That was so cute. I have more to share later in the episode too. Well, let's move on to FastFact 2. I'm calling this the big reveal. Boy, is it? I'm calling this the big reveal. Boy, is it?
并把她们全都系好安全带，但她们兴奋极了。你们真应该看看这张她们脸部的照片。她们对于坐着这个客运货车走区区几百英尺感到无比开心。哦，哦，天哪。我太高兴了。伊莎贝尔，谢谢你分享你的记忆。太可爱了。稍后在这一集中我还有更多要分享的。好吧，让我们进入第二条快速事情。我称之为重大揭秘。天哪，真的是吗？我称之为重大揭秘。天哪，真的是吗？
Yeah. You know, we reveal the documentary crew for the first time, and someone from the documentary crew interacts with someone from the office. This was a big moment. Uh, I mean, not just someone. It's Pam. Yeah.
对。你知道的，我们第一次揭开了纪录片摄制组的面纱，而且纪录片摄制组里的一个人和办公室里的一个人进行了互动。这是一个重大时刻。呃，我是说，不只是某个人。是帕姆。没错。
And Brian. The boom guy. Well Jenny Tan, who runs Office Tally, posted a message to fans before this episode came out just to give you a sense of like how big a deal this moment was in the history of the show. And she said the producers of the show had sent her an email that said this, Hi Jenny, I know the episode summary says, quote, we start to see behind the scenes, but I wanted to let you know how really good tomorrow's episode is.
还有布莱恩。收音师。好吧，运营“办公室花絮”网站的珍妮·坦在该集播出前给粉丝发了一条消息，好让你们了解这个时刻在剧集历史上是多么重大。她说该剧制片人给她发了一封电子邮件，上面写着：嗨，珍妮，我知道剧集总结说，引述，“我们开始看到幕后”，但我只想告诉你明天的这一集到底有多精彩。
You have been great about letting the Office Tele fans know what's going on at the office, but they should really watch tomorrow night. I think they will be sorry if they don't. So watch tomorrow night!" And Jenny Tan went on to say, quote, I have never received an email about an episode before, so I think this is a big deal. Who sent it?
你一直很擅长让“办公室花絮”的粉丝们了解办公室里正在发生的事情，但他们真的应该收看明天晚上的节目。我想如果他们不看的话会后悔的。所以收看明天晚上的节目吧！”珍妮·坦接着说，引述，“我以前从未收到过关于某集节目的邮件，所以我认为这是一件大事。”谁发这封信的？
Someone from the office production. Oh, my gosh. We got a lot of fan questions about the big reveal. I like that you started to whisper. Because sometimes when life gets serious, you'll whisper. You gotta take a dive. Stephanie B from Cleveland, Ohio said, how did you all feel when you saw
办公室制作组的某个人。哦，天哪。我们收到了很多关于这个重大揭秘的粉丝提问。我喜欢你开始说悄悄话。因为有时当生活变得严肃时，你会说悄悄话。你得潜入水底。来自俄亥俄州克利夫兰的斯蒂芬妮·B说，当你看到
the script was featuring the documentary crew? Did you know it was coming? I remember being astonished when I first saw the episode. Tell us everything. What do you know about this decision to bring the camera crew into the story?" And Morgan E. from South Bend, Indiana said, I can remember exactly where I was sitting when you guys smashed that fourth wall. And we saw Brian for the first time. I was stunned, shocked, mouth agape. Even though there had been nods to the crew all along, this felt major and I never saw
剧本里出现了纪录片摄制组时，你们是什么感觉？你们知道它要来了吗？我记得第一次看到这一集时我惊呆了。告诉我们一切吧。关于把摄像团队带入故事中的这个决定，你知道些什么？”印第安纳州南本德的莫根·E说，我还清楚地记得你们打破第四面墙时我坐的地方。我们第一次看到了布莱恩。我惊呆了，震惊了，目瞪口呆。尽管一直以来都有对摄制组的暗示，但这次感觉意义重大，我从未料到
it coming. I need to know everything about this decision. Was there a debate about incorporating the documentary crew into the storyline?" Well, Ange, I reached out to Greg about this, and I have his side of the story. We reached out to director Kelly Cantley, and we got her thoughts on the matter, but why don't we start with us?
它会来。我需要知道关于这个决定的所有事情。把纪录片摄制组融入故事情节中这件事有过争论吗？”好吧，安吉，我为此联系了格雷格，我有他那一侧的故事。我们联系了导演凯莉·坎特利，我们听取了她对这件事的看法，但为什么我们不从我们自己开始呢？
What did we think? Well, okay. This is, oh man, this was a big moment. I put this on a list of like bombshell table read moments. So I remember there were just a few where literally you felt the air go out of the room. Like everyone's reaction. When Pam and Jim kiss in casino night
我们是怎么想的？好吧，好吧。这是一个，哦天哪，这是一个重大时刻。我把这个列入了桌上剧本围读高光时刻的清单中。所以我记得只有那么几次，真的让你觉得房间里的空气都抽空了。就像每个人的反应一样。当帕姆和吉姆在赌场之夜接吻
and we read that at the table read, everyone was like, oh, and then when Dwight and Angela were there for feels. Yes. Making out. Making out, everyone was like, oh my gosh. When we find out that Michael and Jan hooked up in Jamaica. Yes. Making out. We're making out. Everyone's like, oh my gosh. When we find out that Michael and Jan hooked up in Jamaica. Yes.
我们在桌上围读时读到这一段，大家都“哦”了一声，然后当德怀特和安吉拉在那里动真格的时候。对。亲热。动真格的亲热，大家都“哦，天哪”。当我们发现迈克尔和简在牙买加勾搭上的时候。对。亲热。我们在亲热。大家都“哦，天哪”。当我们发现迈克尔和简在牙买加勾搭上的时候。对。
When we find out about Oscar and the senator, when we find out that Pam was pregnant, there were these big moments at the table read. Yeah. And this was one of the biggest. We were like, oh my God, oh my God, we're seeing the crew that have been there all these years and that he knows her well enough that he hugs her in a time when she's vulnerable? Wait, does he hug her?
当我们发现奥斯卡和参议员的事时，当我们发现帕姆怀孕时，围读时有这些大场面。对。而这是最大的一次之一。我们当时想，“哦，天哪，哦，天哪，我们看到了这些年来一直在那里的摄制组，而且他了解她到这种程度，以至于在她脆弱的时候拥抱她？”等等，他拥抱她了吗？
Okay, in the shooting draft, he hugs her. In fact, in the shooting draft, she gets up and goes over to him and they hug. I forgot about that. Yeah. Oh my God. That is not how we ended up filming it. Yeah. That's what we read at the table read.
好吧，在拍摄草稿里，他拥抱了她。事实上，在拍摄草稿里，她站起来走向他，然后他们拥抱了。我把这事给忘了。对。哦，天哪。我们最终拍摄出来的并不是这样。对。那是我们在围读时读到的。
Yeah. Yeah. It was one of those big moments. That's not how we ended up filming it. But that's what we read at the table read. Yeah. Yeah. It was one of those big moments. I remember being conflicted but excited. I was like, oh my gosh, this is, we are really wrapping up the show. If we're going to show the crew, it's real to me now that we are wrapping up storylines. We are peeking behind the curtain.
对。对。那是那些重大时刻之一。我们最终拍摄出来的并不是这样。但那是我们在围读时读到的。对。对。那是那些重大时刻之一。我记得自己内心纠结但又很兴奋。我当时想，“哦，天哪，这真是，我们真的要在收官了。如果要展现摄制组，对我来说现在真实的感觉是我们正在收尾各个故事情节。我们在掀开幕布窥探。”
I think that's what it made me realize, that this is the beginning of our final, final episodes. Yeah. These are definitely the layers of the onion peeling back. Yes. And then of course, none of us wanted Jim and Pam to break up. We wanted to protect Jim and Pam. They were hope in a frame. Hope in a frame. Well, like I said, we reached out to director Kelly Cantley. This was her first episode that she's directing, and this is the script they hand her. So much going on.
我想这就是让我意识到这一点的地方，这是我们最后最后几集的开始。是的。这些绝对是在一层一层地剥开洋葱。是的。然后当然，我们谁都不希望吉姆和帕姆分手。我们想要保护吉姆和帕姆。他们是画框里的希望。画框里的希望。嗯，就像我说的，我们联系了导演凯莉·坎特利。这是她执导的第一集，而这就是交到她手上的剧本。发生了太多事情。
Yeah. Oh my gosh. Here is what she had to say. So Greg Daniels had told me that I would be able to direct an episode season nine, which I was really excited about, but I didn't know which episode. When I got the script for customer loyalty and I read it, I absolutely could not believe that Greg had given me
对。哦，天哪。她是这么说的。格雷格·丹尼尔斯曾告诉我，我将能够执导第九季的一集，我对此感到非常兴奋，但我不知道是哪一集。当我拿到《客户忠诚度》的剧本并阅读它时，我简直不敢相信格雷格竟然给了我
the script where we revealed the documentary crew for the very first time, because I was a new director and that just seemed unbelievably huge. So I started at the beginning of the script and I just kind of worked my way through it. I spent a lot of time on stage. I spent a lot of time looking at angles and talking to Matt's own, our DP, about how to stage things so that they'd be funny
这个我们要首次揭秘纪录片摄制组的剧本，因为我是一个新导演，这看起来简直大得不可思议。所以我从剧本的开头读起，一点一点理清它。我在片场花了大量时间。我花了很多时间研究机位，并和我们的摄影指导马特·索恩讨论如何进行场景调度，好让画面既好笑
and so they'd be interesting and look like it belonged in our show. If I had gotten this script as a first time director, I would have pooped my pants and handed it back. I know. And like hard pass. This is the same thing we talked about with Brian Cranston is you say yes,
又有趣，并且看起来属于我们的剧集。如果我作为第一次当导演的人拿到这个剧本，我肯定会吓得屁滚尿流然后把它交回去。我知道。而且绝对会坚决拒绝。这跟我们和布莱恩·克兰斯顿聊过的是一样的，就是你先答应下来，
but then you don't know the episode you're gonna get. Yeah. This was a huge episode. It had a bunch of toddlers. Yep. It had this major reveal. It had multiple locations. Yeah. Well, I'll tell you from my point of view, because I had been working as a producer this season. I knew this was coming. So it was really fun for me to sit in that table read and have everybody else find out. But this storyline of Pam being comforted by the boom operator
但你根本不知道你会分到哪一集。对。这一集太大了。里面有一群幼儿。对。有这个重大揭秘。有多个拍摄地点。对。好吧，我从我的角度来告诉你们，因为我这个赛季一直在担任制片人。我知道这事要发生。所以对我来说，坐在围读会上看其他人发现真相真的很有趣。但帕姆被收音师安慰这个故事情节
was actually a pitch from Mindy Kaling that went all the way back to season three. Oh, wow. Yeah. And I remember Greg bringing it up to me and John over the summer during our producer sessions for season nine. So I reached out to Greg because I wanted to kind of get this backstory.
实际上是明迪·卡aling的一个提案，一直追溯到第三季。哦，哇。是的。我记得格雷格在第九季的制片人会议期间，在夏天向我和约翰提过这件事。所以我联系了格雷格，因为我想了解一下这个背景故事。
And here's what Greg said. Greg said, yes, it was originally a pitch for Pam when she was in New York going to art school. The idea was that she was on the subway and she was getting hassled by someone, and the boom operator would drop his boom mic and come in to save her. And once he was revealed, he would become a little bit of a character on the show. Maybe she would have a few meals with him. The idea was that we wanted to make people worry that she was maybe drifting apart from Jim while she was in New York.
格雷格是这么说的。格雷格说，是的，这最初是为帕姆在纽约上艺术学校时准备的一个提案。当时的构思是她在地铁里，被某个人骚扰了，然后收音师放下收音杆出面解救了她。一旦他露面，他就会成为剧中的一个小角色。也许她会和他吃几顿饭。这个想法是，我们想让观众担心，她在纽约时可能正在和吉姆渐行渐远。
Greg said it was pretty much the story role that Rich Summer ended up playing. And he said he loved this idea, and everyone in the writers' room loved this idea, but they felt like it was something we should save for later, kind of like what you were saying, Angela. He said it kind of made you think about the documentary crew too much for like a season three moment. Yeah, that's too soon. I agree. He said it would be hard to put that back in the bottle for the rest of the season. Yeah, because you're like, what is the guy standing there? Yes, you'd be thinking about them too much.
格雷格说这基本上就是里奇·萨默最后扮演的角色剧情。他说他很喜欢这个想法，编剧室里的每个人也都喜欢这个想法，但他们觉得这是应该留到以后再用的东西，有点像你刚才说的，安吉拉。他说这会让大家对纪录片摄制组的思考过多，不适合第三季的节点。是的，那太早了。我同意。他说很难在剩下的剧集里把这个精灵重新塞回瓶子里。是的，因为你会想：那个家伙站在那儿干嘛？是的，你会过多地关注他们。
But Greg said he always thought it was a really creative pitch. And he said, but considering it was season nine, and he was aiming at the documentary airing at the end of season nine, he said we wouldn't need to put anything back in the bottle. So they could go with this. And he said, you know, remember we discussed putting a little conflict between Pam and Jim for season nine, because we didn't want it to be all smooth sailing.
但格雷格说他一直觉得这是一个非常有创意的提案。而且他说，考虑到已经是第九季了，而且他的目标是让纪录片在第九季末播出，他说我们不需要把任何东西塞回瓶子里。所以他们可以用这个。而且他说，你知道，还记得我们讨论过在第九季为帕姆和吉姆制造一点冲突吗，因为我们不想让一切都一帆风顺。
And so, he said, Jim was gonna go to Philly, kinda like Pam going to New York, and this was an opportunity for some drama and tension, so that the eventual happy ending would feel even better. He wants fans to know there was never any way that he wasn't gonna give Jim and Pam a happy ending. But the boom operator seemed like something that would worry the audience. And he said, it was really the only plausible relationship that Pam could have had all these
所以，他说，吉姆要去了费城，有点像当年帕姆去纽约那样，这是一个制造戏剧性和张力的机会，这样最终的快乐结局感觉才会更好。他想让粉丝们知道，他绝对不可能不给吉姆和帕姆一个快乐结局。但收音师似乎是那种会让观众感到担心的东西。并且他说，这真的是帕姆在这多年里唯一可能产生、而我们却一无所知的合理解的关系，因为摄制组从未被纳入过画面中。
years that we wouldn't know anything about because the crew's never been included in the footage. Yeah. And he said, it did worry the audience. They hated Brian so much. Oh, they hated him instantly. Yeah. I felt so bad for Chris, who played Brian, because,
是的。并且他说，这确实让观众担心了。他们太讨厌布莱恩了。哦，他们瞬间就讨厌他了。是的。我为饰演布莱恩的克里斯感到难过，因为，
oh my lord, the minute he hit the screen, people were like, hold up, buddy. Yes. What are you doing putting your hand on Pam's back? I don't think so. Yeah, Greg said it definitely served its purpose. All right, moving on to fast-pack number three, which we've touched on a little bit.
哦天哪，他一出场，人们就想：等等，老兄。是的。你把手搭在帕姆背上是在干嘛？我想并没有吧。是的，格雷格说这绝对达到了它的目的。好了，让我们继续第三条快速事实，我们刚才已经稍微触及了一点。
How was this received? Well, many reviewers loved it. E! Online named the reveal one of the best TV moments of the week. Newsday called the scene historic and said that the moment between Jim and Pam fighting and the cameraman making an appearance was a lot to take in, but that the scene was properly done. The Huffington Post called it quote, huge and shocking. But some people took issue with it. Critics and fans alike wondered is this the moment that the documentary crew finally steps in because Pam is emotional?
反响如何？嗯，许多评论家都很喜欢它。E!在线将这个揭秘评为本周最佳电视时刻之一。 《新闻日报》称这一场景具有历史意义，并表示吉姆和帕姆吵架与摄像师出场的时刻信息量很大，但这个场景处理得很恰当。 《赫芬顿邮报》称其为，引述，“巨大而令人震惊”。但也有人对此提出了异议。评论家和粉丝们都在疑惑：这是因为帕姆情绪激动，纪录片摄制组才终于介入的时刻吗？
So like when Michael drove his car into a lake. Yes. They're not like, wait, wait, Michael, you're driving into a lake. Correct. We had a letter from Jennifer P. in Spanaway, Washington, who said, I left Pam and I don't like to see her cry, but the documentary crew stops filming because of it? Here's a list of things the documentary crew did not stop filming for. How about allowing Andy to float around in a lake in a sumo suit and not helping him get out?
就像迈克尔把车开进湖里那样。是的。他们并没有说：“等等，等等，迈克尔，你正在把车开进湖里。”没错。我们收到了来自华盛顿州斯帕纳韦的珍妮弗·P的一封信，她说：“我爱帕姆，我不喜欢看她哭，但纪录片摄制组却因为这个而停止拍摄了？”以下是纪录片摄制组没有停止拍摄的事情列表：比如允许安迪穿着相扑服在湖里漂浮而不帮他出来？
Allowing Dwight to start a fire in the office. That's a good one. Locking us all inside. Yes. Allowing Michael to jump off the roof onto a bouncy castle. Or Dwight to ride a bicycle on a tightrope? Yes! How about letting Uncle Al wander around the city when he goes missing from Phyllis' wedding? Oh, Uncle Al, I didn't even think about that one. Yes! How about filming Kevin as he passes out in his car
允许德怀特在办公室里纵火。这个不错。把我们全都锁在里面。是的。允许迈克尔从屋顶跳到充气城堡上。或者让德怀特在钢丝上骑自行车？是的！再比如允许奥尔叔叔在菲莉斯的婚礼上走失后在城市里游荡？哦，奥尔叔叔，我甚至都没想到那个！是的！再比如拍摄凯文在车里昏过去的样子
when they're worried about the dog in the parking lot? Allowing Jim to stab into snowmen with a pointy umbrella with the possibility of Dwight being inside. Allowing Angela to hire a hit man to injure Oscar. To commit a possible crime. They did not stop Dwight from riding a bike across a high wire. They did not stop Michael from attempting to frame Toby.
当他们在停车场担心那只狗的时候。允许吉姆用带尖的雨伞刺雪人，而德怀特可能就在里面。允许安吉拉雇杀手去伤害奥斯卡。去实施可能的犯罪。他们没有阻止德怀特骑自行车横跨高空钢丝。他们没有阻止迈克尔试图陷害托比。
They allowed Dwight to shoot Stanley with animal tranquilizers. And Jennifer says, I'm sure there are plenty more. So yes. Well Jennifer, I totally agree. Although in those instances, none of them turned to the camera operator and said, Brian, what am I doing wrong? Yes. Pam, and this was a big note that we had, which was that Pam has to break the wall. Yeah.
他们允许德怀特用动物镇静剂射击斯坦利。珍妮弗说，我相信还有很多。所以，是的。好吧，珍妮弗，我完全同意。虽然在那些情况下，他们中没有一个人转向摄像师说：“布莱恩，我做错了什么？”是的。帕姆——这是一个我们注意到的重大细节——那就是帕姆必须打破第四面墙。是的。
Pam broke the wall. Yes. Brian did not. Correct. The documentary crew did not interfere until Pam initiated that contact. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Well, that's all I have for Fast Facts. I'll get into the weeds on how we filmed that big reveal later
帕姆打破了墙。是的。布莱恩没有。正确。直到帕姆发起这种接触之前，纪录片摄制组并没有进行干涉。嗯-hmm。嗯-hmm。好吧，这就是我关于快速事实的全部内容。稍后当我们剖析那个时刻时，我将深入探讨我们是如何拍摄那个重大揭秘的
when we break down that moment. Well, let's take a break, because when we get back, I have some call sheet tidbits to kick us off. I love your call sheet tidbits. We are back. Here are my call sheet tidbits. First of all, you guys, when Steve Burgess sends me the call sheets, he always includes a photo from his day. It's the cutest thing.
好吧，我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，我有一些通告单的趣闻来拉开序幕。我喜欢你的通告单趣闻。我们回来了。这是我的通告单趣闻。首先，各位，当史蒂夫·伯格给我发通告单时，他总是会附上一张他当天的照片。太可爱了。
And for this week, he had some flowers blooming in his yard, and he sent me a picture, and so I sent him one back of my flowers. It just makes me so happy. I feel like I'm trading emails with my dad. SONIA DARA GILMORE I totally get it, Angela. The other day, I wrote to Randy Cordray, and I was like, I know I'm not reaching out to you every week anymore, but I just wanted to say hi. ANGELA WOLFSON I know, they're such a wonderful part of this journey with us.
这一周，他的院子里有一些花儿在盛开，他给我发了一张照片，所以我回赠了他一张我的花儿的照片。这让我觉得好幸福。我觉得自己就像在跟爸爸互通邮件。我完全理解，安吉拉。前几天，我写信给兰迪·科德雷，我说，我知道我不再每周都联系你了，但我只是想打个招呼。我懂，他们是我们这段旅程中如此美妙的一部分。
And I feel that way about Kent Subornak too. Yeah. They are kind of like the dad of the production. Yeah. So our first day of filming started on November 26, 2012. For this week, the weather averaged a high of 74 degrees and a low of 50 degrees, and we had rain Wednesday through Friday. That sounds so pleasant.
我对肯·苏博纳克也是这种感觉。是的。他们有点像制片厂的大家长。是的。所以我们的第一天拍摄始于2012年11月26日。这一周，天气平均最高气温为74华氏度，最低为50华氏度，从周三到周五我们都下了雨。听起来真宜人。
It's a nice time of year. Yeah. Well, that's your weather report from the call sheet. And that's when we were filming this episode, November 2012. Well, this episode opens with a very cheeky cold open. Dwight is going through a file cabinet over by the accountant's desks, and he is complaining because he's like, there's so many dead accounts in here, do we ever clean this thing out? And he finds a letter, an old letter, from Robert Dunder, implying that he might be in possession of perhaps the Holy
一年中很好的时光。是的。好吧，这就是来自通告单的天气预报。那就是我们拍摄这一集的时候，2012年11月。好吧，这一集以一个非常厚颜无耻的冷开场开场。德怀特正在会计桌子旁翻找一个文件柜，他在抱怨，因为他说，这里有这么多的死账，我们到底有没有清理过这个东西？然后他找到了一封信，一封来自罗伯特·邓德的旧信，暗示他可能拥有某种圣杯，并且把它藏在办公室的某个地方。
Grail and that he has hid it somewhere in the office. Yeah. The letter reads, a valuable artifact has come into my possession. I have hidden it until such time as a person of strong intellect may safely recover it. This golden chalice is of immeasurable historical and religious significance." Pam overhears this. She's like, oh my gosh, this is a classic Jim prank. And she calls him. Yeah, and she's asking him about it. And he's like, Pam, I am too busy to do pranks on. Oh my gosh. He remembers. He did this years ago. He spent weeks on it. And Dwight only just now
是的。信上写道：“一件珍贵的文物落入了我的手中。我将其藏匿起来，直到某位智力超群的人能够安全地将其取回。这座金圣杯具有不可估量的历史和宗教意义。”帕姆无意中听到了这个。她说：“哦，天哪，这是个经典的吉姆恶作剧。”她给他打电话。是的，她问他这件事。而他说：“帕姆，我忙得很，没空搞恶作剧。”哦，天哪。他记起来了。他几年前做过这个。他为此花了几个星期。而德怀特直到现在才找到。
finds it. Yeah, Jim says he stayed late every night for a month. He had a lot more free time back then. And he says, the Dunder Code. Well, here is the Dunder Code breakdown of clues. Are you ready? I'm ready. First clue is a light bulb which reveals a message written in invisible ink higher than numbers go. Dwight immediately is like, up the ceiling above accounting. Next clue is a key with a tag marked X. Oscar solves this one. He's like, Annex.
是的，吉姆说他连续一个月每天都加班到很晚。他那时候有更多空闲时间。他说：“邓德密码”。好吧，这里是邓德密码的线索解析。准备好了吗？我准备好了。第一条线索是一个灯泡，它揭示了一条用隐形墨水写在比数字更高的位置的信息。德怀特立刻反应过来：会计部门上方的天花板。下一条线索是一把挂着标有X的标签的钥匙。奥斯卡解开了这个。他说：档案室。
It must be something in there. Over in the Annex in a locked bottom drawer in Clark's desk is a scroll reading, CDs in trotty or seat of entrance. a scroll reading, Seedies Entrotee or Seat of Entrance. This leads everyone over to front reception where Dwight cuts open a sofa cushion to find five red playing cards. Kevin immediately is like, that's a flush because you know Kevin, he's our card guy. Dwight then emerges from the bathroom. He's clearly gone in the toilet somehow and he's found a little, I don't know, like a little pallet stacker, you know, like a little warehouse. Little toy.
肯定有东西在那里面。在档案室里克桌子上的一个锁着的底层抽屉里，有一张滚动条写着：“大厅里的CD或入口的座位”。一张滚动条写着：“大厅里的CD或入口的座位”。这把所有人引向了前台接待处，德怀特切开了一个沙发垫，找到了五张红桃扑克牌。凯文立刻说：“这是一副同花顺”，因为你懂凯文，他是我们的纸牌专家。接着德怀特从洗手间里冒出来。他显然不知怎么进到厕所里了，然后他找到了一个，我不知道，就像是一个小型托盘堆垛机，你知道的，就像是一个小型仓库。小玩具。
Yes. Like warehouse forklift. Forklift, that's the word. And everyone is cheering. They're like, it's the warehouse, the warehouse. They go down to the warehouse. They're tearing the warehouse apart. They can't find it.
对。就像仓库里的叉车。叉车，就是这个词。每个人都在欢呼。他们说：“是仓库，是仓库。”他们跑到仓库里。他们把仓库翻了个底朝天。他们找不到。
This cuts to Glenn, who's enjoying a donut as he dunks it into coffee in a golden chalice. Yeah. I guess he find it. This cuts to Glenn, who's enjoying a donut as he dunks it into coffee in a... Golden chalice. Yeah. I guess he found it. He found it a long time ago. I have one bullsh** card to play in this whole cold open. Just one?
镜头切到格伦，他正一边享受着甜甜圈，一边把它浸入一个金圣杯的咖啡里。是的。我猜他找到了。镜头切到格伦，他正一边享受着甜甜圈，一边把它浸入一个……金圣杯的咖啡里。是的。我猜他找到了。他很久以前就找到了。在这个冷开场里，我有一张废话卡要打。只有一张？
Mm-hmm. Ha-ha-ha. As Dwight is going and finding all the clues, it cuts back to Jim at Athlead, and Jim says, Oh, I can't wait for Dwight to get to the end and find the fake grail. Or wait, is it? Wait, did I get a grail? I can't remember. I'm sorry, Jim would remember. Did you see that golden chalice that Glen
嗯-hmm。哈哈。当德怀特去寻找所有线索时，镜头切回了在Athlead的吉姆，吉姆说：“哦，我等不及看德怀特走到终点并找到那个假圣杯了。”或者等等，是吗？等等，我拿到了圣杯吗？我记不清了。对不起，吉姆会记得的。你看到格伦用来蘸甜甜圈那个金圣杯了吗？
is dipping his donut in? It's very elaborate. He had to special order that or go to a store. You would remember buying a golden chalice. Am I wrong? You're not wrong. We have what I was calling a fan catch but could call a bullsh** card from Randy C. in Columbia, Maryland, who said, how do all these artifacts still exist after the various things that the office has been through, such as the fires that both Ryan and Dwight set? Yeah, how's that thing still up in the ceiling above accounting if like, remember, Oscar fell through the ceiling, a cat fell through the ceiling. Okay.
非常精致。他一定得特别定制或者去店里买。你绝对会记得自己买过一个金圣杯。我错了吗？你没说错。我们有一张我称之为“粉丝抓包”但也可以算作来自马里兰州哥伦比亚的兰迪·C的废话卡的卡片，他说：“在经历办公室经历的种种事情之后，比如瑞恩和德怀特放的火，这些文物怎么可能都还存在？”是的，为什么那东西还在会计部门上方的天花板上，如果像你们记得的那样，奥斯卡曾从天花板上掉下来，一只猫也从天花板上掉下来。好吧。
It's still just like right up there. Of all the clues, I believe they would all still be in their places. The toilet? No one cleans. Michael has done so much to the toilets. Okay, the two spots are the toilet and above accounting. The ceiling. Yeah.
它依然就在那里。在所有的线索中，我确信它们本该都不在原来的地方了。洗手间？没有人打扫。迈克尔对洗手间做过那么多事。好吧，两个地方是洗手间和会计部门上方。天花板。是的。
I'm just saying, how are these clues still there? I did want to point out some background details and just give a big shout out to our crew. At 44 seconds, we see flashback footage of Jim at his desk planning this whole thing. Yes. And he's got, you know, his old wardrobe, his old floppy hair. They tried, they tried to make his floppy hair, but I didn't buy it. Well, I wanted to point out all the ways
我只是想说，这些线索怎么可能还都在那儿？我确实想指出一些背景细节，并向我们的剧组成员致以崇高的敬意。在44秒的时候，我们看到了吉姆在办公桌前策划这一切的回忆镜头。是的。他留着（你知道的）旧发型，旧的蓬乱头发。他们尝试过，他们试图弄出他那蓬乱的发型，但我没买账。嗯，我想指出所有的细节
that the set had been taken back in time. So there's a little piece that you can see over Jim's shoulder of the manager's office, and it's been redressed to be Michael's office. There is no desk for Andy or Nellie, you know, that desk that was added to the Phyllis Stanley clump. And there is not a desk for Pam in the Jim Dwight clump. It's back to that stack of paper boxes that it was in the very early seasons.
说明布景是如何被带回过去的。所以在吉姆肩膀上方可以看到经理办公室的一小部分，它已经被重新布置成了迈克尔的办公室。没有安迪或内莉的桌子（你知道的，就是加在菲莉斯和斯坦利那一堆里的那张桌子）。在吉姆和德怀特那一堆里也没有帕姆的桌子。它变回了早期剧集里那堆纸箱子。
I love that. Yeah, great detail. Before we end this cold open breakdown and get into the episode, I have two background catches. Number one, Meredith has a new wig. She's a blonde this week. Number two, Angela is wearing pants. Oh, pants.
我喜欢这个。是的，很棒的细节。在我们结束这段冷开场剖析并进入正片之前，我有两个背景抓包。第一，梅雷迪思换了新假发。她这周是个金发女郎。第二，安吉拉穿着裤子。哦，裤子。
That must have been comfy. I know. Well, I have one last thing before we move on. I have a cold open snark. Oh, you perked up. It's our favorite thing. I get very excited. Oh, we text each other, I have a snark.
那一定很舒服。我知道。好吧，在我们继续之前我还有最后一件事。我有一个冷开场吐槽。哦，你精神来了。这是我们最喜欢的部分。我变得非常兴奋。哦，我们给对方发短信说，我有个吐槽。
We're like, I'm sorry. I'm sorry, kids, we're gonna be a little bit late for school. Jenna has a morning snark. I gotta hear it, sorry. It's so true. Yeah. It's so true. It's just your face lit up when I said it.
我们就像是：抱歉。抱歉，孩子们，我们上学要迟到一会儿了。珍娜有个早晨吐槽。我得听听，抱歉。太真实了。是的。太真实了。就在我这么说的时候，你的脸亮了起来。
You sat up. Oh! Okay. Okay. I just need to note. Okay. That Pam is on the phone in the background every step of the way.
你坐直了身子。哦！好吧。好吧。我只需要指出一点。好吧。帕姆在每个环节的背景里都在打电话。
She's on the phone giving Jim a play by play of this whole search that Dwight is on. I just think it's interesting that he's able to step away from work for that to get real-time updates on his prank. Right. I see where you're going. Okay. Yeah. You got it. Yeah, I got it. But Pam's the bad guy this season. Oh, now. Come on. That's okay though. Yep. Yep. Yep. Fine.
她在打电话向吉姆实时汇报德怀特正在进行的这场搜索的进展。我只是觉得很有趣，他竟然能从工作中抽身出来，实时更新他的恶作剧进展。没错。我明白你的意思了。好吧。你懂的。是的，我懂。但帕姆是这一季里的坏人。哦，拜托。得了吧。不过没关系。对。对。对。好吧。
Fine. Well, I just sent you a link to an article titled Jim Halpert Sucks. I know you did. And it's about the season. I know. Finally. I feel like finally maybe people are seeing it through a different lens. Okay. Now we're starting the episode.
好吧。好吧，我刚刚给你发了一篇题目的链接叫《吉姆·哈尔珀特真烂》。我知道你发了。而且是关于这一季的。我知道。终于。我觉得终于有人或许能透过不同的镜头来看待他了。好吧。现在我们要开始正片了。
Let's... Oh my God. You sound like a cartoon. You sound like a cartoon. I want to do more voiceover work. Now we're starting the episode. I want to do more voiceover work. So do I.
让我们……哦，天哪。你听起来像个动画片人物。你听起来像个动画片人物。我想做更多配音工作。现在我们要开始正片了。我想做更多配音工作。我也是。
So you're going to try some stuff out on the pod. I really do. I wanna be in an animated show. Yeah, don't have to do my hair. Don't have to do her hair, never. Never again. Never again. Do I have to worry about the back of my head?
所以你要在播客里尝试一些东西。我真的想。我想加入一个动画节目。是的，不用做发型。不用做她的发型，绝不。再也不用了。再也不用了。我需要担心我脑后勺吗？
I mean, I let it go anyway, but. Lady, I'm wearing a hat today because I'm trying to do fashionable hat because I haven't dyed my roots and I didn't do the back of my hair. Oh, you have a roots day. It's the 50s. I'm fully 50s now and I've started to stop doing the back of my hair. What's going on?
我的意思是，反正我都随它去了，但是。女士，我今天戴着帽子，因为我想弄个时尚的帽子，因为我没有染发根，而且我脑后勺的头发没弄。哦，你有个发根日。已经是50岁了。我现在完全是50岁的状态，而且我开始不再打理我脑后勺的头发了。怎么回事？
You know, I feel like when you're young you wear a hat because you're like, I didn't wash my hair or whatever, I wear a hat. But now as you get older, it's like, I didn't do my roots. I've got some grays and the back of my head is a hot mess. Put on a hat. Those are the three reasons I put a hat on today. Well, I think you look really cute. I think it looks cute too.
你知道的，我觉得年轻时你戴帽子是因为你觉得：我没洗头或者别的什么，我戴顶帽子。但现在随着年纪增长，就像是：我没弄发根。我有一些白头发，而且我脑后勺简直是一团糟。戴上帽子吧。这就是我今天戴帽子的三个原因。好吧，我觉得你看起来真的很可爱。我也觉得看起来很可爱。
All right, time for the ANPA show. I know. That's my, another one of the characters I can do for any of the voiceover folks listening. Can you sustain that? Sure I can. Oh, you can. You really can. Hey, Ange.
好了，安帕秀的时间到了。我知道。那是我的，另一个我可以为所有收听的配音迷们表演的角色。你能维持那个声音吗？我当然可以。哦，你行。你真的行。嘿，安吉。
I mean, write the show for her, please. All right. For real, we open with Nellie in the conference room with Aaron and Pete. Yeah, apparently Aaron and Pete are part of this social media initiative that Nellie has set up. So they're trying to have an online presence for Dunder Mifflin.
我是说，请为她写个剧作吧。好了。说真的，开场是内莉在会议室里和阿伦还有皮特在一起。对，显然阿伦和皮特是内莉建立的那个社交媒体计划的一部分。所以他们正试图为邓德米夫林建立网络存在感。
Yeah. They've created a fake profile for a really cool guy named Derek McBlack, and I guess it's just Pete in sunglasses. And they're trying to get likes and followers, and they're creating fake accounts to get those. And at the same time, they're just being flirty and super cute. And Nellie says, I consider myself a genius for putting the two of them together. First of all, I just want to say kudos to our writers for making Nellie's job a job.
是的。他们为一个叫德里克·麦克布莱克的超酷帅哥创建了一个假个人资料，我猜那其实就是戴着太阳镜的皮特。他们正试图获得点赞和粉丝，并且正在创建虚假账户来获取这些。与此同时，他们还在调情，超级可爱。内莉说：“我觉得把他们两个凑到一起的自己简直是个天才。”首先，我只想对我们的编剧表示赞赏，他们把内莉的工作变成了一项真正的工作。
She really does have special projects. Now, do we need these special projects? Right. Probably not, but you know, the social media initiative, special. Yeah. Makes it legitimate. All right. We had a fan question from Chris W. from the New Forest, England. When Aaron and Pete are working on their grand social media initiative, they set up a fake profile for Derek McBlack. Aaron informs Nellie that Derek is in fact just Pete in sunglasses. We only get a brief glimpse of McBlack, but I'm not convinced this is Pete in sunglasses. Would the real Derek McBlack please stand up?
她确实有特殊项目。现在，我们需要这些特殊项目吗？对吧。可能不需要，但是你知道的，社交媒体计划，挺特别。是的。让它变得合法。好吧。我们收到了来自英国新福林的克里斯·W的一个粉丝提问。当阿伦和皮特在搞他们宏大的社交媒体计划时，他们为德里克·麦克布莱克建立了一个假个人资料。阿伦通知内莉说德里克其实只是戴着太阳镜的皮特。我们只能短暂地瞥一眼麦克布莱克，但我并不确信这就是戴着太阳镜的皮特。请真正的德里克·麦克布莱克站出来好吗？
I didn't think it looked like Pete either. Me either. I reached out to see Burgess and Steve said, Chris, you're right. That doesn't look like Jake. Steve said, I don't have any info. I'm pretty sure we didn't ever take a picture of Jake. My guess is it's a stock photo that the art department picked of a guy in sunglasses. Good catch, Chris.
我也觉得看起来不像皮特。我也不觉得。我联系了史蒂夫·伯格，史蒂夫说：“克里斯，你说得对。那看起来不像是杰克。”史蒂夫说：“我没有任何信息。我很确信我们从来没拍过杰克的照片。我猜那是艺术部门挑选的一个戴墨镜男人的图库照片。”抓得好，克里斯。
I totally agree. Yeah. Here's one little catch in this scene. Did anyone else notice that Jake Lacey has a cold? I didn't. Yeah. He has a cold in this episode. How do you know? For sure.
我完全同意。是的。这个场景里有一个小细节。有没有其他人注意到杰克·莱西感冒了？我没有。是的。他在这一集里感冒了。你怎么知道的？百分之百。
He's like, yeah, exactly. He's like, this is my cold. That's what he sounds like. He's like, come on, guys. He literally says that in the conference room later. He's like, come on, guys, what's this all about? I did not notice this, but I just want to say, you can do person with cold voiceover. Thank you, put it on my resume.
他就像是，对，没错。他就像是：这就是我的感冒。他听起来就是这样。他就像是：拜托，伙计们。他后来在会议室里 literalmente（字面意思）就是这么说的。他就像是：拜托，伙计们，这到底是怎么回事？我没有注意到这一点，但我只想说，你可以用感冒的声音进行配音。谢谢，请把它写进我的简历里。
Yep. Aaron's going to have a talking head where she's giddy about getting to work with Pete. She talks about how well they work together, and she gets all flustered. Yeah. She's clearly sweet on him. Yeah. She's like, I probably work well with the girl, or a guy, or someone I'm into.
没错。阿伦有一个Talking Head（面对镜头独白），她在其中为能和皮特一起工作而兴奋不已。她谈到了他们合作得有多好，并且她变得有点局促不安。是的。她显然对有好感。是的。她说：“我可能跟一个女孩合作得很好，或者一个男孩，或者某个我有好感的人。”
Not that I'm into Pete. Yes. She's very cute, isn't it? Next up, we see Jim at Athlead. We find out that one of their biggest investors has requested a lunch meeting. And he just says, Hey, guys, is it cool if we just do it a little early? Because remember, I have to get back to Scranton today. And they're like, Sure. Yeah, no problem.
并不是说我对皮特有好感。是的。她非常可爱，不是吗？接下来，我们看到吉姆在Athlead。我们发现他们最大的投资者之一要求举行一次午餐会。而他只是说：“嘿，伙计们，如果我们稍微提前一点开会，行吗？因为记住，我今天必须赶回斯克兰顿。”他们说：“当然。行，没问题。”
Yeah. And then Jim has this talking head he's very excited about Cece's ballet recital he's taught her a signature move the Cece spin and kiss and he demonstrates it he's very cute dad moment. I absolutely love the guy who is walking in the background of this talking head. Oh no. Did you see him? I watched it three times. No, I didn't see him. Oh my gosh. It's such good background acting.
是的，然后吉姆有了这个Talking Head，他对此感到非常兴奋，那是关于西西的芭蕾舞汇报演出的，他教了她一个招牌动作——西西旋转加飞吻，并且他演示了这个动作，这是一个非常可爱的父亲时刻。我绝对喜欢那个在这个Talking Head背景里走来走去的家伙。哦，不。你看到他了吗？我看了三遍。不，我没看到。哦，天哪。这是非常棒的背景表演。
He's walking by and Jim does the spin and the kiss and he just kind of looks in to the conference room as you would if someone was spinning and whatever for a camera. It's very good job. Very, very good job to the person who did this cross. Well, now we're going to set up a Daryl Dwight storyline. Daryl arrives to Dunder Mifflin.
他从旁边走过，吉姆做了旋转和飞吻，他只是往会议室里看了一眼，就好像如果有人在镜头前旋转或做别的什么，你也会那样做一样。干得非常漂亮。向这个做交叉走位的演员致以非常非常高的敬意。好吧，现在我们要开始设置达里尔和德怀特的故事情节了。达里尔到达了邓德米夫林。
He has an athlete bag and Dwight immediately is like, why do you have that? Why are you and he calls the company Stumpenny, AKA Stupid Company. That really made me laugh. It made me laugh too. This is when Daryl tells Dwight that he's gonna work for Stumpenny. Uh-huh. Dwight is shocked. He's so mad. He calls Jim, he's furious.
他带着一个运动员包，德怀特立刻问：你为什么带着那个？你为什么——而且他把这家公司叫做 Stumpenny，也就是“愚蠢公司”。这真的把我逗笑了。这也把我逗笑了。这就是达里尔告诉德怀特他要去 Stumpenny 工作的时候。呃-huh。德怀特惊呆了。他气坏了。他给吉姆打电话，怒不可遏。
He's like, hey Halpert, what's the big idea? First you jump ship, now you're stealing Daryl too? When will it end? And Jim says, we'll take your worst fear and multiply it by infinity. Dwight says, you won't stop until you've poached us all. And Jim goes, yeah, even you. And then here's one of my favorite lines
他就像是：嘿，哈尔珀特，这是什么鬼主意？先是你跳槽，现在你连达里尔也要挖走？什么时候是个头？吉姆说：我们会把你的最大恐惧乘以无限大。德怀特说：你们不把我们全挖光是不会罢休的。然后吉姆说：对，甚至包括你。然后这里有我整集中最喜欢的台词之一
from the whole entire episode. Dwight says, no, I'll be damned if I'm gonna let us lose me. I know. That made me laugh so hard. Well, now Pam is gonna approach accounting because she needs to ask Angela if she's heard anything about the Irish American Cultural Center mural. Guess what, guys? Angela's husband, the senator, recommended Pam to be
德怀特说：不，如果我眼睁睁看着我们失去我，那我可就太该死了。我知道。这把我笑得前仰后合。好吧，现在帕姆要走向会计部门，因为她需要问安吉拉是否听到有关爱尔兰裔美国人文化中心壁画的事情。猜猜怎么着，伙计们？安吉拉的丈夫，那位参议员，推荐帕姆成为
the artist for this big mural project in Scranton. Yeah, I loved this callback. Remember, the senator had come to the office with coffee during the target. It was in deleted scenes. And here we have this footage because the Senator is looking for Angela but wants to talk to Oscar. And Daryl says, I think they're in the warehouse. So we've got this great footage
斯克兰顿这个大型壁画项目的艺术家。是的，我很喜欢这个呼应。还记得那位参议员在靶场时曾带着咖啡来到办公室吗。那是在被删减的片段里。在这里我们有了这个镜头，因为参议员在找安吉拉，但想和奥斯卡谈谈。而达里尔说：我想他们在仓库里。所以我们有了这个精彩的镜头
of the Senator noticing Pam making her mural. Pam has a talking head where she says, Senator Lipton helped me submit my design for a new mural on a downtown building. And she's waiting to hear. She's trying to downplay it. She's like, I mean, there are so many people they would go with. Why would they go with an unknown like me
拍到参议员注意到帕姆在画她的壁画。帕姆有一个Talking Head，她说：利普顿参议员帮我提交了市中心一栋建筑的新壁画设计方案。她在等消息。她试图低调处理。她就像是：我是说，有那么多人他们可以选。为什么他们要选像我这样的无名小卒
when they could have a big name like Tracy Fleab? Oh, Tracy Fleab. Big time mural artist in Scranton. Yeah. I know for a fact that Greg likes funny names. I feel like a bunch of names were pitched and they loved Fleab, Tracy Fleab. Sorry to all the real Fleab's out there. There are some.
当他们可以拥有像特雷シー·弗利布这样的大牌时？哦，特雷西·弗利布。斯克兰顿的大牌壁画艺术家。是的。我确信格雷格喜欢有趣的绰号。我觉得他们脑子里闪过了好几个名字，而他们最喜欢弗利布，特雷西·弗利布。向所有现实生活中的弗利布家族致歉。确实有一些。
I'm sure, but it is an interesting sounding name. It is. You must know that. Yes. If your last name is Fleab. You know. You know. It's like this family we knew growing up when we lived overseas. Their last name was Herb. Herb.
我确信，但这是一个听起来很有趣的名字。是的。你一定知道这一点。是的。如果你的姓氏是弗利布。你知道的。你知道的。就像我们海外居住时认识的一个当地家庭。他们的姓氏是赫布。赫布。
Herb. Like basil? Is an herb? No, like E-R-B. Herb. Oh. And guess what? The dad's first name was. I'm scared.
赫布。像罗勒叶（Basil）那样的一种香草（Herb）？不，就像 E-R-B。赫布。哦。你猜怎么着？爸爸的名字是。我好害怕。
Herb. No, it wasn't. Yes, it was. Stop it. Herb Herb. Come on. His name was Herb Herb? His name was Herb Herb. Come on. His name was Herb Herb? His name was Herb Herb. But I'm just saying,
赫布。不，不是。是的，真的是。别闹了。赫布·赫布。拜托。他的名字叫赫布·赫布？他的名字叫赫布·赫布。拜托。他的名字叫赫布·赫布？他的名字叫赫布·赫布。但我只是想说，
Herb Herb knew he had a funny name. Why did Herb Herb's parents do that to him? Maybe they had a sense of humor. Yeah, sometimes it happens. That's a head shaker. You're an herb, you're a fleab. Dweeb fleab. No, no one would do that. No. No. Herb, herb. It was real. Okay. Well, Angela has no information.
赫布·赫布知道自己的名字很有趣。为什么赫布·赫布的父母要对他做这种事？也许他们很有幽默感。是的，有时候会发生这种事。真是让人直摇头。你叫赫布，你叫弗利布。白痴弗利布。不，没人会这么做。不。不。赫布，赫布。这是真的。好吧。好吧，安吉拉没有任何消息。
She doesn't know if they've gone with Tracy fleab. She doesn't know anything. She doesn't. This is when Pam is gonna share that she's off to Cece's recital. Oscar could not be less enthusiastic. He's like, okay, whatever. I have a question.
她不知道他们是不是选了特雷西·弗利布。她什么都不知道。她确实不知道。这时候帕姆要分享她要去参加西西的汇报演出了。奥斯卡表现得不能再冷淡了。他就像是：好吧，随便吧。我有个问题。
What? Why is this dance recital in the middle of a work week? They often are. No. Sometimes. It must be a school thing. I mean, could you make it harder for working parents to get there for their kid?
什么？为什么这个舞蹈汇演会在工作日的中间举行？它们经常这样。不。有时会。这一定是个学校的活动。我是说，你还能把时间选得更难让上班族父母赶去陪孩子吗？
Why do you have this in the middle of the day, in the middle of a work? It's not even the end of the day. I mean, I go to a lot of things at the kids' school, but it's always like at the end of the day. It's like an evening thing, which is always a heavy lift because you're like, oh my God. I will say though, in elementary, when they're really little, I mean, this is little, this is like preschool age, kindergarten age, When they're really little, sometimes their big events are like at 1 30 or 2 p.m. And you do, you have to scramble to get there as a working parent. I mean, okay. I thought it was a little odd.
为什么要把这个安排在白天中间、工作中间？甚至都不是一天的结束。我是说，我经常去参加孩子们学校的活动，但总是在快放学的时候。就像是一个晚上的活动，这总是让人压力山大，因为你会想：哦天哪。不过我要说的是，在小学阶段，当他们真的很小的时候，我是说，这很小，这就像学龄前、幼儿园的年龄，当他们真的很小的时候，有时候他们的大型活动就是在下午1:30或2点。而你确实需要手忙脚乱地作为上班族父母赶过去。我是说，好吧。我觉得这有点奇怪。
So after that Pam talking head about Tracy Fleab, there would have started this deleted storyline about Angela's weird bent foot. Remember that? Yes. Yes. And we talked about it with Kelly Cantley when we interviewed her, because she was my foot double one day,
所以在关于特雷西·弗利布的那个帕姆的Talking Head之后，本来会开始一段被删掉的关于安吉拉奇怪的歪脚的故事情节。还记得那个吗？对。是的。我们在采访凯莉·坎特利时跟她聊过这件事，因为她有一天是我的脚替，
and we both had to contort our feet. Well, when I was looking in my digital clutter for this episode, I mean, I know I've already shared a photo. I found more. There were more pictures. So in addition to finding all of these extra photos from the fake foot fitting, I also found an email I sent to you. Oh, here's what it's titled, Ugg and Ugg Some More.
而且我们两个都得把脚扭曲。好吧，当我在我的数字杂物里寻找这一集的资料时，我是说，我知道我已经分享过一张照片了。我找到了更多。还有更多照片。所以除了找到所有这些来自假脚试穿的额外照片之外，我还找到了一封我发给你的邮件。哦，标题是这样的：《又是一堆糟心事》。
Oh, boy. I couldn't wait to open this email. Okay. It starts with this. I had to get here super early for this random prosthetic foot gag that Greg loves and I bet it won't even make it into the episode. Oh no, and it didn't. And get this, a prosthetic specialist guy
天哪。我迫不及待地想打开这封邮件。好吧。它是这样开头的。我为了这个格雷格很喜欢的随机假脚恶作剧不得不大清早赶到这里，我敢打赌它甚至都不会剪进这一集里。哦不，果然没有。而且你听说了吗，一个义肢专家
had to come to my house over Thanksgiving break to take measurements of my foot. And this morning I had to meet with Phil Shea and Alicia to figure out wardrobe that will go over the fake foot leg. And then we had to take photos of the fake foot leg. And it's only 930 a.m. Oh, boy. It's so great that you have these because this was like sort of pre-texting where if
感恩节假期不得不来我家给我的脚量尺寸。今天早上我还得跟菲尔·希亚和艾丽西亚开会，商量要套在假脚腿外面的戏服。然后我们还得给假脚腿拍照。现在才早上九点半。天哪。你们能保留这些邮件真是太好了，因为这有点像是发短信的前身，如果你
you did want to fill someone in, you wrote it in email. We would write emails. Yes. And one of the reasons I emailed you rather than called you invented is that you had the morning off and you had a baby. You had Weston. And so I was like, I'm not going to rant to her about this prosthetic fake foot gag that Greg wants. I'm just going to email her and she'll see it when she can. Oh my goodness. Well, you called it.
想把某事告诉某人，你就会把它写在邮件里。我们会写邮件。是的。我给你发邮件而不是给你打电话的原因之一是，你那天早晨休息，你当时有个孩子。你有了韦斯顿。所以我当时想，我才不要对她抱怨格雷格想要这个义肢假脚恶作剧呢。我只要给她发个邮件，等她有空的时候她就会看到了。我的天哪。好吧，你真神了。
It wasn't in the episode. No, no. You're like, all this effort. I interrupted my Thanksgiving break. A man came to my house. Oh my gosh. Well, now Pam and Cece are in the car and they call Jim. They call daddy.
它确实没出现在这一集中。不，不。你会想，付出这么多努力。我打断了我的感恩节假期。一个男人来到了我家。哦天哪。好吧，现在帕姆和西西在车里，她们给吉姆打电话。她们给爸爸打电话。
This is really cute. So sweet. But this is where Pam is gonna find out that Jim is still in Philly and he's not gonna make the recital. This investor might back out and Jim can't leave. So Jim says, Pam, will you please film the recital? And he sort of starts talking to her
这真的很可爱。太甜了。但这就是帕姆将要发现吉姆仍然在费城，而且他赶不回来看汇演的时候。这位投资人可能会打退堂鼓，吉姆不能离开。所以吉姆说，帕姆，求求你把汇演拍下来好吗？他开始用一种
kind of condescending about how to film it. And she's like, look, I know how to point a rectangle at something and film it. Mm-hmm. And then he's like, okay. And then it's time to say goodbye. And then there's this pause. And then he's like, hey, Pam, you have to press end, you know, which is sort of meant to be like a dig at her phone skills. Yeah. Lady.
居高临下的语气跟她说话，教她怎么拍。而她则说，听着，我知道怎么把一个长方形对准某个东西并把它拍下来。嗯。然后他说，好吧。然后该说再见了。接着是一段停顿。然后他说，嘿，帕姆，你得按结束键，你知道的，这有点像是对她手机使用技能的挖苦。是啊。大姐。
Why can't Jim just hang up the phone? This is the scene. Oh, that people were pissed off about? For so many reasons. I saw the mail for this episode and I couldn't believe it. Where should I begin? I'll begin with Amanda C. from Montreal, Canada. Amanda says, I have to go on a little rant about Jim,
为什么吉姆就不能直接挂断电话？就是这个场景。哦，这是人们感到很生气的场景吗？因为有太多的原因了。我看到这集的邮件时，简直不敢相信。我该从哪里开始呢？我从加拿大蒙特利尔的阿曼达·C开始。阿曼达说，我得对吉姆发一通牢骚，
but maybe not from the moment you think. What absolutely grinds my gears about Jim's behavior is when Pam is on the phone with him in the car and he implies that she doesn't know how to use her phone to video the recital by saying, see Pam, you still need to hang up the phone. Excuse me, sir. She is driving.
但也许不是从你想的那个时刻开始。最让我对吉姆的行为感到火大的是，当帕姆在车里跟他打电话时，他暗示她不知道怎么用手机把汇演录下来，他说，看吧，帕姆，你还是得挂断电话。对不起，先生。她在开车。
Can you not hang it up yourself? And then it will automatically end the call on her phone, Samantha L. from Tampa, Florida said. The thing I actually cannot get past is the incident when Pam is in the car on the way to Cece's recital. Why is Jim giving Pam such a hard time for being bad with technology because she doesn't hang up the phone? Pam is driving with your child in the backseat.
难道你自己不能把它挂断吗？然后它就会自动结束她手机上的通话，来自佛罗里达州坦帕市的萨曼塔·L说。我实际上无法释怀的事情是，当帕姆在去西西汇演的路上坐在车里时发生的那个插曲。为什么吉姆要因为帕姆不挂断电话而把她技术不好这事拿出来大做文章？帕姆车后座上还坐着你的孩子呢。
You hang up the phone, Jim. You're not the one that would need to take your hand off the wheel of a moving vehicle. Let's see. Samantha goes on to say, who's the one who's really bad with the cell phone technology, huh? Spoiler alert, not Pam.
吉姆，你去挂断电话。又不是你需要把手从行驶中车辆的方向盘上拿开。咱们看看。萨曼塔接着说，到底是谁对手机技术一窍不通啊，嗯？剧透一下，不是帕姆。
Another letter from Nora E. in New Orleans, Louisiana. I want to go on record to say that the tipping point moment when Jim has clearly gone full a**hole is in this episode when he's on the phone with Pam and he berates her for not hanging up the phone. She's driving, he's at work. He's clearly not in a huge rush to return to his meeting since he's able to stay at his desk and what,
路易斯安那州新奥尔良的诺拉·E发来的另一封信。我要郑重声明，吉姆彻底变成个混蛋的那个临界点就是这一集里，当他在电话里跟帕姆通话时，他因为她没挂断电话而痛骂她。她在开车，他在上班。他显然一点也不急着回去开会，因为他能一直坐在办公桌前，然后怎么着，
have a gotcha moment with his own wife? This scene in the car makes me so deeply angry. I need this full dickhead moment to be acknowledged. I love that she puts full in front of her curse word. I know. Full asshole. I wanna use that. He's gone full asshole.
还要跟自己的妻子来个“抓到你了”的时刻？车里的这一幕让我感到无比愤怒。我需要这个彻头彻尾的混蛋时刻得到承认。我喜欢她在她的脏话前面加上“彻头彻尾”这个词。我知道。彻头彻尾的混蛋。我想用这个词。他彻底变成个混蛋了。
I know, I know. So, Ange, it's literally what you said. You said it, you're like, why can't he hang up the phone? This is just three of the letters we got about this moment. But this is very good foreshadowing for what is gonna happen later. And I think an interesting dynamic in their relationship, which is that, and I think some relationships have this,
我知道，我知道。所以，安吉，这简直就是你说的。你当时就说了，你说，为什么他就不能挂断电话？这只是我们收到的关于这个时刻的信件中的三封。但这对于接下来要发生的事情来说是非常好的伏笔。我认为这也是他们关系中一个有趣的动态，那就是，而且我认为有些关系里也有这个，
they've got the gotcha person. Oh, I gotta point out the little thing, gotcha. You know, you said that you are good at cleaning out the fridge,, gotcha. You know, you said that you are good at cleaning out the fridge, but gotcha found a rotten tomato or whatever it is. You know, the gotcha people, the gotcha moments, which are just like so toxic for a relationship. It's petty.
他们有那种喜欢抓别人把柄的人。哦，我得指出那个小毛病，抓到你了吧。你知道的，你说过你很擅长清理冰箱，抓到你了。你知道的，你说过你很擅长清理冰箱，但是被抓到有一个烂西红柿或者别的什么。你知道的，喜欢抓把柄的人，那些抓包的时刻，对一段关系来说简直太有毒了。这很琐碎。
Pettyness. It's pettyness. Yeah. Yeah. But Jim's in a mood, he's stressed, he's not handling it well. Yeah. In conclusion, I hope that us discussing it today on the podcast has brought some of you relief
太琐碎了。这太琐碎了。是啊。是啊。但吉姆今天心情不好，他压力很大，他处理得不太好。是啊。总之，我希望我们今天在播客中讨论这件事能给你们中的一些人带来宽慰，
because the number of heated letters we got about this moment, I felt it. We also asked Kelly Cantley about directing this scene, and here's what she had to say. Cece in the car, surprisingly, Cece in the car was really hard to shoot because Cece was a little girl and little kids don't do lines. So Jenna, I don't know if you remember, we shot all of your dialogue and then we shot lots of both of us taking turns just saying the lines.
因为我们收到关于这个时刻的激烈信件实在太多了，我能感受到。我们还询问了凯利·坎特利关于导演这一场景的感受，以下是她的说法。车里的西西，出人意料的是，车里的西西真的很难拍摄，因为西西是个小女孩，小孩子是不会按台词演的。所以珍娜，我不知道你还记不记得，我们拍完了你所有的台词，然后我们拍了我们俩轮流只说台词的大量镜头。
I think we started with you doing it and then we wanted to go from you to the little girl so we would see you talking. So you did it a few times where you would just say her line and she would say it back and I believe I did it a bunch of times on the speaker in the car. So I actually had forgotten that until I watched the episode again. I actually did remember that. I had such a great rapport with those little girls, not to toot my own horn, but I'm 50 now, which is the decade of tooting your own horn. It's time to toot. Bailey and Sienna, I just loved them so much.
我想我们是从你开始的，然后我们想要从你切换到那个小女孩，这样我们就能看到你在说话。所以你拍了好几次，你只是说她的台词，而她再重复回来，而且我相信我在车里的免提电话上也这么拍了很多次。所以我其实已经忘了，直到我又看了一遍这一集。我其实还记得。我和那些小女孩关系可好了，不是我自吹自擂，但我现在50岁了，这是个可以自吹自擂的十年。是时候自吹自擂了。贝利和西耶娜，我太喜欢她们了。
We would do a thing where we would do like repeat me. I would say their line and they would say their line. We made a little game out of it. They did great. I thought it was so cute. Yeah. Those girls were so cute. Yeah. Those girls were so cute. Well, lady, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, I have a copy of Dwight's loyalty oath and everyone's coffee order.
我们会玩一个游戏，就是玩那种“跟我重复”。我会说她们的台词，然后她们说她们的台词。我们把这个变成了一个小游戏。她们表现得很棒。我觉得这太可爱了。是啊。那些女孩太可爱了。是啊。那些女孩太可爱了。好吧，大姐，我想我们该休息一下了。当我们回来时，我有德怀特的效忠誓词的副本以及每个人的咖啡订单。
Okay. We are back. Welcome back to office, ladies. Is this another one of your- This is another one of my characters. Oh my gosh. I'm not sure who I am or what I am, but I think it's a good voice. I think it's perfect for like maybe you're like a little tiny lizard that like lives. Yes, I live in a crevice. Yes, you live in a crevice.
好的。我们回来了。欢迎回到办公室女士们。这是你的又一个——这是我的又一个角色。我的天哪。我不太确定我是谁或者我是什么，但我觉得这是个好声音。我觉得这非常完美，就像可能你是一个生活在——是的，我生活在一个缝隙里。是的，你生活在一个缝隙里。
Surprise! Surprise! That lizard is here. That's it, I put it on your resume. Can do cute lizard. Can anybody take this lizard voice and put it onto a a lizard and we'll post it on office ladies pod in stories Not a feed post
惊不惊喜？意不意外？那个蜥蜴来了。就这样，我把它写进你的简历里了。会发出可爱的蜥蜴叫声。有没有人能把这个蜥蜴的配音放到一个蜥蜴身上，然后我们会把它发在office ladies pod的故事动态里，而不是发动态主页
Just in stories Who are you? What's your character? I don't know. I'm just trying to match you. Are you another like amphibian? What are you? Who's that guy? the voice of reason guy My character has wild ideas and has lots of enthusiasm My character doesn't always want to go with the flow We're not writing it okay, just doing the not writing it, okay? We're just doing the voices for it. Okay.
只发在故事动态里。你是谁？你的角色是什么？我不知道。我只是想配合你。你是另一个两栖动物吗？你是什么？那家伙是谁？那个理性的声音家伙。我的角色有疯狂的想法，而且充满热情。我的角色并不总是想随波逐流。我们不是在写剧本，好吧，只是不做剧本创作，好吗？我们只是在为它配音。好吧。
We're back. And Nellie and Pete and Erin are celebrating their first real like. They've got a non-fake person to like Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. And they are very excited. They do their little handshake. It's really cute. And Nellie is like, oh, no, what have I done?
我们回来了。内莉、皮特和艾琳正在庆祝他们第一个真正的喜欢。他们找到了一个不是假装喜欢邓德姆弗林的人。是啊。他们非常兴奋。他们击了个掌。这真的很可爱。然后内莉就像是，哦，不，我都干了些什么呀？
Yeah. She said, Andy is just starting to be nice to me. And now I've driven his girlfriend into the arms of a younger man. And she has cc'd Andy on all the incriminating correspondence in which she tells them not to hold back, to make sure their social media presence is hot, hot, hot. Yeah, she says I did everything but unzip their pants for them. And now she's on a mission to undo all of it. I have to point out in the background of Nellie's Talking Head, you know, we were always doing background for each other.
是啊。她说，安迪才刚开始对好我。而现在我却把他女朋友推向了一个年轻男人的怀抱。而且她在所有那些煽动性的信件中都抄送了安迪，在信中她告诉他们不要有所保留，要确保他们的社交媒体账号热度火热火热。是啊，她说我只差没帮他们解开裤子了。而现在她正肩负着撤销这一切的使命。我必须指出，在内莉的访谈背景中，你知道的，我们总是互相配合做背景。
Super cutesy background, like Pete and Erin are just continuing very animated, flirty, handshakey cutesiness. Dwight is now going to announce that he's ordering coffee for the whole team and presents a sign-up sheet. Phyllis looks below the top flap and discovers it's actually a loyalty pledge. She's trying to be sneaky and get them to sign it. Well, after this episode aired, NBC released a copy of Dwight's loyalty pledge, and here's what it had to say. By writing my name in the column below,
超级可爱的背景，比如皮特和艾琳继续着非常生动、调情、击掌的可爱互动。德怀特现在要宣布他要为整个团队订咖啡，并出示了一张签名表。菲莉丝看了看顶部的翻盖下面，发现这实际上是一份效忠誓言。她正试图鬼鬼祟祟地让他们在上面签字。好吧，在这一集播出后，全国广播公司发布了一份德怀特的效忠誓言复印件，以下是它的内容。通过在下面的栏目中写下我的名字，
I do hereby resolve to swear an oath of loyalty and obedience to Dunder Mifflin and its affiliates, here and after, company, for life plus 10 years. My loyalty and priorities will be wholly with company and no side projects or extracurricular endeavors, aka moonlighting at dumb sounding companies, including but not limited to athlete. I also promise not to take tips or kickbacks
我在此郑重决定宣誓对邓德姆弗林及其子公司（以下简称公司）效忠和服从，终身外加十年。我的忠诚和首要任务将完全属于公司，不得有任何副业或业余活动，也就是在那些听起来很蠢的公司兼职，包括但不限于运动员。我还承诺不接受小费或回扣
or any form of payola, as such term is generally defined in the radio industry, in exchange for giving special treatment to any customers, here and after customers. My devotion to the company shall be nothing less than unconditional obedience, and I shall be prepared at all times to give my life to uphold this oath in this life and the hereafter. One coffee order maximum per name, no pizza. And then it listed everybody's coffee order.
或任何形式的贿赂（该术语在广播行业中的一般定义），以换取对任何客户（以下简称客户）的特殊对待。我对公司的忠诚绝不低于无条件服从，我将随时准备献出我的生命来维护今生和来世的这一誓言。每个名字最多订一杯咖啡，不准点披萨。然后上面列出了每个人的咖啡订单。
Can I just say, I feel like he had to put no pizza because it's come up before. They've had a coffee order and someone has also asked for pizza. Yes. All right, here is the coffee order for the folks at Dunder Mifflin. Phyllis ordered a banana fruit smoothie.
我能说句话吗，我觉得他一定得写上“不准点披萨”，因为以前发生过这种事。他们点过咖啡，结果有人还点了一份披萨。是的。好吧，这是为邓德姆弗林的各位准备的咖啡订单。菲莉丝点了一杯香蕉水果冰沙。
Stanley ordered a small decaf. Daryl ordered a double latte, lotsa latte. Oscar ordered a Vente Kai tea, Misto, half soy. Kevin ordered a cappuccino. Pete. Is that different from a cappuccino? I think it's what Kevin thinks is a cappuccino. Pete. Is that different from a cappuccino? I think it's what Kevin thinks is a cappuccino. He wrote Captain Chino.
斯坦利点了一杯小杯低因咖啡。达里尔点了一杯双份拿铁，超大杯拿铁。奥斯卡点了一杯大杯茶拿铁，半豆奶。凯文点了一杯卡布奇诺。皮特。这跟卡布奇诺有什么区别吗？我想这就是凯文认为的卡布奇诺吧。皮特。这跟卡布奇诺有什么区别吗？我想这就是凯文认为的卡布奇诺吧。他写的是“长官奇诺”。
Okay. Pete ordered a cappuccino with cinnamon. Clark ordered a tall and black like my women. Nellie ordered a black tea, any, with lemon like my men. Erin ordered a black tea, any, with lemon, like my men. Erin ordered a vanilla blendy thing, five sugars, happy face. Meredith ordered an Irish coffee, extra Irish. And this goes to your theory, Angela.
好吧。皮特点了一杯加肉桂的卡布奇诺。克拉克点了一杯大杯的黑咖啡，就像我喜欢的女人那样黑。内莉点了一杯红茶，随便什么茶，加柠檬，就像我喜欢的男人那样。艾琳点了一杯红茶，随便什么茶，加柠檬，就像我喜欢的男人那样。艾琳点了一杯香草冰沙特调，加五份糖，笑脸。梅雷迪思点了一杯爱尔兰咖啡，超浓爱尔兰风味。这印证了你的理论，安吉拉。
Creed ordered a pastrami on rye, fries, coke, nothing to drink. Yeah. There you go. Angela did not order any. No, she didn't. Angela Martin and Angela Kinsey don't want to be part of your coffee order. Angela Martin does not want to be stimulated. She doesn't. And Angela Kinsey doesn't drink coffee. Angela Kinsey doesn't drink coffee. Dwice now bursts into the annex and he says, Clark, I need any complaints pertaining to Darryl in the past few weeks. I want it broken down by keywords. And Clark's like, listen, that's gonna be tough.
克里德点了一份黑麦熏牛肉三明治、薯条、可乐，什么都不喝。是啊。你看吧。安吉拉没有点任何东西。不，她没有。安吉拉·马丁和安吉拉·金西不想参与你们的咖啡订单。安吉拉·马丁不想被咖啡因刺激。她才不想呢。而且安吉拉·金西不喝咖啡。安吉拉·金西不喝咖啡。德怀特现在冲进附楼，他说，克拉克，我需要过去几周与达里尔有关的所有投诉。我要按关键词分类。克拉克说，听着，这可不容易。
We use Windows 95. And Dwight's like, fine, just print it out. Then this cuts to that hilarious dot matrix printer that's like, tiki, tiki, yaki, tiki. It's going to take forever. And when we asked Kelly Cantley what memory she had from shooting this episode, this was one of the scenes she mentioned. Here's what she said. The scene where Dwight goes into Clark and tells him to print all the complaints. I looked and looked at that scene
我们用的是Windows 95。德怀特说，行吧，那就把它打印出来。然后画面切到了那个滑稽的点阵打印机，发出“滴叽，滴叽，咔叽，滴叽”的声音。这要打印到何年马月啊。当我们问凯利·坎特利对拍摄这一集有什么记忆时，这就是她提到的场景之一。她是这么说的。德怀特走进克拉克办公室让他打印所有投诉的那个场景。我看了又看那个场景，
and I could not figure out how it was gonna be funny until we shot it. And Matt's own brilliant operator dropped the camera down to just over the machine on to Dwight and Clark. And then I thought it was just so funny. It makes me laugh every time I see it. I think this scene is so funny because it is the callback to Clark being frustrated by our just dinosaur technology.
却怎么也想不出它要在哪里才搞笑，直到我们拍了它。而且马特自己的杰出摄像师把摄像机向下移到机器上方，正对着德怀特和克拉克。然后我觉得这太搞笑了。每次我看到它都会笑。我觉得这个场景太搞笑了，因为它是对克拉克对我们老掉牙的恐龙技术的沮丧的一种呼应。
Yeah, talk about old tech. He's surrounded by old tech. Dwight is now going to hold a conference room meeting about customer loyalty. What is it? Can you hold it in your hand? Can you dump it on a woman? No, because it's an idea. What does it mean? This whole time a man has been sitting at the front of the conference room, Dwight is now going to introduce him as Mr. Romanco, a client of 20 years who came in today enraged at Darryl, who was distracted because he was
是啊，说到老技术。他被老技术包围着。德怀特现在要在会议室召开一个关于客户忠诚度的会议。它是什么？你能把它拿在手里吗？你能把它倒在女人身上吗？不能，因为它是一个想法。它意味着什么？这个会议室的前面一直坐着一个男人，德怀特现在要介绍他是罗曼科先生，一个合作了20年的客户，今天气冲冲地走进来，对达里尔发火，因为达里尔分心了，他在
working on outside projects. And Mr. Romanco was like, no, no, no, I wouldn't classify this as rage. He seems a bit confused. Well, there was a scene that would have come previous to this that sort of explains it all and set up the whole scene. In the shooting draft, it read like this, a client, Mr. Romanco, a meek little man, enters the office tentatively. Dwight spots him. Dw A client, Mr. Romanco, a meek little man, enters the office tentatively. Dwight spots him. Dwight says, Mr. Romanco, right away, so sorry you felt the need to come in.
忙着做外部项目。而罗曼科先生却说，不，不，不，我不会把这归类为愤怒。他看起来有点糊涂。好吧，本来在这之前还有一个场景，它基本上解释了一切，并且奠定了整个场景的基础。在拍摄剧本中，它是这样写的：一个客户，罗曼科先生，一个温顺的小个子男人，试探性地走进办公室。德怀特发现了。一个客户，罗曼科先生，一个温顺的小个子男人，试探性地走进办公室。德怀特发现了。德怀特说，罗曼科先生，真是不好意思，让你觉得有必要亲自跑一趟。
Mr. Romanco says, I didn't. You called, but it's such a small matter. Maybe we should just, Dwight says, I understand, but we take customer loyalty very seriously here. Emergency conference room meeting, everyone. Mr. Romanco is like confused. He's like, what? And he turns to Mr. Romanco and says,
罗曼科先生说，我没想来。是你打电话叫我来的，但这只是件小事。也许我们应该直接——德怀特说，我理解，但我们这里对客户忠诚度非常重视。紧急会议室会议，大家注意。罗曼科先生感到很困惑。他说，什么？然后他转向罗曼科先生说，
I hope you have nothing planned for the whole afternoon. And Mr. Romanco says, actually I do have. And Dwight pushes Romanco into the conference room and then shouts to everyone, I rate customer coming through. Yes. When we get back to the conference room, Darryl is going to say, I'm so sorry, we were a day late on your delivery,
我希望你整个下午都没有安排。罗曼科先生说，其实我还真有。然后德怀特把罗曼科推进了会议室，接着对大家喊道，愤怒的客户来了，大家让让。是的。当我们回到会议室时，达里尔要开口了，我很抱歉，我们的货送迟了一天，
but two of our trucks were down for repairs and I don't see this ever happening again. And Mr. Romanko is like, fine, great. He's satisfied with that answer. He wants to leave. Yeah, he's like, good for me. Dwight's like, no, Mr. Romago is angry. And Darryl forgot that loyalty is the key to relationships. Well, Nellie is going to be like, I agree. Yes. She sees her way out now,
但是我们有两辆卡车在维修，我保证这种事以后绝不会再发生了。然后罗曼科先生说，行吧，太好了。他对这个答案很满意。他想离开。是啊，他说，对我挺好。德怀特却说，不，罗曼科先生很生气。而达里尔忘记了忠诚是人际关系的关键。好吧，内莉要表态了，我同意。是的，
and she's going to take it. She says loyalty is everything, and they should all ask themselves if they've been faithful in their relationships. Stanley is like, uh-uh, he's not going to participate in this conversation. Nellie says Daryl is dating Dundra Mifflin, but flirting with athlete on the side. Then they start using Aaron as an example. Like, what would it be like if Aaron, who is in a relationship with Andy, was flirting with someone on the side, like maybe Creed. And Creed's line, he's so funny, he's like,
她现在看到了出路，并且她要抓住它。她说忠诚就是一切，他们都应该扪心自问，自己在感情中是否一直忠诚。斯坦利说，呃-Uh，他才不参与这个对话。内莉说达里尔在和邓德姆弗林谈恋爱，却在私底下跟运动员眉来眼去。然后他们开始拿艾琳举例子。比如，如果艾琳和安迪在谈恋爱，却在私底下跟别人眉来眼去，比如跟克里德，那会是什么样的情景。而克里德的台词，他太搞笑了，他说，
yeah, I'll play that out. He's like, sure, yeah, let's see what, let's play that out. And imagine during all of this, poor Mr. Romaco, he's just like, can I go? And this conference room scene was so fun to shoot. We broke and laughed several times. And I loved this little brief exchange
行啊，那我陪你们演下去。他说，当然，行啊，让我们看看，让我们把这出戏演下去。大家想象一下，在这一切当中，可怜的罗曼科先生，他简直就像是在说，我能走了吗？这个会议室的场景拍起来太有趣了。我们中途笑场了好几次。我特别喜欢安吉拉和艾琳之间
between Angela and Erin. I want to play it. Well, I think it would be immoral for Erin to cheat on Andy. Oh, I'm sorry. Didn't you cheat on Andy? Yes. And he didn't like it. I loved that too. I loved when you said yes, and he didn't like it. I loved that too. I loved when you said,
这段简短的对话。我想把它放出来。好吧，我觉得艾琳背叛安迪是不道德的。哦，不好意思。难道你没有背叛过安迪吗？是的。而且他很不高兴。我也很喜欢这个。我特别喜欢你说“是的，而且他很不高兴”。我也很喜欢这个。我特别喜欢你说，
yes, and he didn't like it very much. Yes, and I'm really put out, and he didn't like it. One of our favorite things as a cast, we've talked about this before, is to have a big group scene where everyone has a moment, and this was one of those scenes. Everyone in the conference room had something hilarious that they contributed. Yes, and by the way, Mr. Romanco was great. Yes. Guest star shout out to Mr. Romanco played by Bob Blooberman.
是的，而且他非常不高兴。是的，而且我很生气，而他很不高兴。作为演员，我们最喜欢的事情之一——我们以前也讨论过这一点——就是拍一个每个人都有高光时刻的大型群戏，而这就是其中一场戏。会议室里的每个人都贡献了搞笑的台词。是的，顺便说一句，罗曼科先生演得太棒了。是的。向客串明星鲍勃·布卢伯曼致敬。
He was originally a lawyer who left law to become an actor in 1995. Well, Bob has crossover connections with both you and I. You want to hear them? Yes. Bob and I have both had roles on Spin City and Strong Medicine. And Angela, your crossover connections are Hot in Cleveland, New Girl, and Fresh Off the Boat. Bob, we've worked on so many of the same shows. I know. He's appeared in over a hundred TV shows, dozens of commercials, and voiceover spots. Bob. Hook us up.
他最初是一名律师，1995年辞去律师职务成为了一名演员。好吧，鲍勃跟你和我都有共同的熟人关系。你想听听吗？是的。鲍勃和我都在《城市大赢家》和《妙手仁心》中演过角色。而安吉拉，你的共同熟人关系有《克利夫兰福利》、《杰茜驾到》和《初来乍到》。鲍勃，我们演过那么多相同的剧集。我知道。他出演过一百多部电视剧、几十个商业广告和配音节目。鲍勃。
Yeah. We have so many voices. We can do many voices. We can do a lot. Hey now listen Bob, I got this guy too. I can do this one. He works at a tire shop. Tim's Tire Town.
帮我们牵线搭桥吧。我们可以模仿很多声音。我们可以模仿很多种。我们可以做很多事。嘿，现在听着，鲍勃，我也会这个家伙的。我能模仿这个。他在一家轮胎店工作。蒂姆轮胎小镇。
I always say, if you're gonna get your beauty done, get your beauty done right. That's what she says. See, look at us. Bob. What can't we do? Bob. Probably voice over.
我总是说，如果你要做美甲，那就做好。她是这么说的。瞧，看看我们。鲍勃。有什么是我们做不到的？鲍勃。大概是配音吧。
Well should we head on over to Cece's recital because it is underway. Yes it is and I have a few more things to share about this day. Kelly had made sure I had the day off so when we filmed these scenes I could be there just right off camera. You had to be. I know. That morning the girls got to go through right off camera. You had to be. I know. That morning, the girls got to go through hair and makeup. They were very excited. I have adorable pictures of these tiny little ladybugs
好吧，我们是不是该去西西的汇演现场了，因为汇演已经开始了。是的，确实开始了，关于这一天我还有几件事要分享。凯利确保我那天放假了，所以当我们拍摄这些场景时，我就在镜头外面陪着。你必须得在场。我我知道。那天早上，女孩们去做了发型和妆容。她们非常兴奋。我有这些可爱的小瓢虫
in those big hair and makeup chairs, and they look so tiny in them. Debbie and Sherry in hair and makeup took such great care of them. And Isabel was already really familiar with the hair and makeup trailer. So she was actually very excited that she got to sit in the chair and not just pop in and say hi to me.
坐在那些宽大的美发化妆椅上的可爱照片，她们坐在里面显得太娇小了。美发和化妆师黛比和谢里把她们照顾得无微不至。而伊莎贝尔对发型和化妆房已经很熟悉了。所以她其实非常兴奋，因为她能坐在椅子上，而不只是探个头进来跟我打个招呼。
Well, what I loved about our hair and makeup folks, Angela, is that, you know, these little girls didn't really need hair and makeup. No. They fussed over them. Yes. They made it an event. This day was like a whole event for these little girls. So they would like maybe put their hair in a ponytail
好吧，安吉拉，我们的发型和化妆师最让我喜欢的一点是，你知道的，这些小女孩其实并不需要做发型和化妆。对。他们对她们大加夸赞。是的。他们把这变成了一场活动。对这些小女孩来说，这一天就像是一场盛大的活动。所以他们可能会把她们的头发扎成马尾辫
or pigtails or something, but they would linger. And they would brush their faces, even if there wasn't any makeup on it. It was the cutest thing. It was so cute. In fact, one time Isabel was on set, and I think I've shared this before, and I think my forehead was shiny.
或者双马尾之类的，但他们会磨蹭很久。他们会抚摸她们的脸，即使脸上根本没化什么妆。这太可爱了。太可爱了。事实上，有一次伊莎贝尔在片场，我想我以前分享过这个，当时我的额头好像出油发亮了。
They said, Angela, you have a little bit of shine, and they powdered my forehead. So, Isabel walked into the hair and makeup and she said to Sheri, can I get a little shine? Yeah, because she thought that was what you got. Yes. And they just put their hair up in little ponytails and then, you know, they got a tiny little bit of chapstick and a little bit of shine. So sweet. Well, the location of this recital was the 20th Century Woman's Club in Eagle Rock. And I asked Steve Burgess, what was involved
他们说，安吉拉，你有点出油了，然后他们给我的额头扑了点粉。于是，伊莎贝尔走进发型和化妆间，对谢里说，我能补点高光吗？对，因为她以为那是你才有的待遇。是的。他们只是把她们的头发扎成小马尾辫，然后，你知道的，她们涂了一点点润唇膏和一点点高光。太甜了。好吧，这个汇演的地点是鹰岩的20世纪妇女俱乐部。我问了史蒂夫·伯格斯，
on the production end when you have a bunch of little kids on set? Because I know they can only work certain hours, they have to have breaks, they have to have tutors, they have to have a parent or guardian. Steve said since these were just three and four-year-olds, they didn't really have to go to school, to have a parent or guardian. Steve said since these were just three and four-year-olds, they didn't really have to go to school,
当片场有一群小孩子时，制作方需要做些什么？因为我知道他们只能工作特定的时间，必须有休息时间，必须有家教，必须有父母或监护人陪同。史蒂夫说，因为这些只是三四岁的孩子，他们其实不用去上学，不需要有父母或监护人陪同。史蒂夫说，因为这些只是三四岁的孩子，他们其实不用去上学，
but they did have a school teacher there because it's required by California law, but they didn't really make them go to school and that the shooting was very short. It was very short and they did have a big room for everyone with chairs and the girls like, I mean, literally they had coloring books and crayons and little games, and we all hung out together.
但他们确实在那里配备了一名学校老师，因为这是加州法律要求的，但他们并没有真的让他们去上学，而且拍摄时间非常短。非常短，而且他们确实为每个人准备了一个带有椅子的巨大房间，女孩们，我的意思是，字面意义上有涂色书、蜡笔和小游戏，我们大家都在一起玩。
And when I rewatched the episode with my daughter and we watched the dancing, she's right in the middle at the very first opening shot. It's her and Maya, and they're right in the middle next to Cece. And she's like, oh, mom, Maya knew the dance perfectly. And when we watched, we both got tickled because Isabel got distracted by her shoes. She looks down at her feet.
当我带着女儿重温这一集并看舞蹈时，她就在最开始的第一个镜头正中央。那是她和玛雅，她们就在西西旁边正中间。她说，哦，妈妈，玛雅把舞蹈动作记绝了。当我们看的时候，我们两个都咯咯笑了起来，因为伊莎贝尔被自己的鞋子分散了注意力。她低头看着自己的脚。
Aw. And she was like, what am I doing? I was like, well, you did love shoes. I don't know. Maybe you were looking at your shoes. And there was an extra scene that they did with the little gals where they all poke their heads around the big curtain before they go on stage. That one didn't make it in the episode, but it is in deleted scenes.
啊。她当时就像是在想，我在干嘛呢？我说，好吧，你确实很喜欢鞋子。我不知道。也许你当时在看你的鞋子。还有一个额外的场景，是关于这几个小家伙的，她们在走上舞台之前把头从大幕布周围探出来。那个镜头没有剪进正片里，但它在删减片段里。
Well, while this recital is going on, Pam is in the audience and she's filming. But guess what? She gets a phone call. Yes, and she's so excited. It's the city of Scranton. Yes, she got the job painting the mural over Tracy Fleab. She got the job. Well, the other parents around her are not pleased that she took this phone call. They're shushing her. They're saying, you are very rude. Very rude.
好吧，在这个汇演进行的同时，帕姆坐在观众席里进行拍摄。但你猜怎么着？她接到了一个电话。是的，她太兴奋了。是斯克兰顿市政府打来的。是的，她得到了在特雷西·弗利布上方画壁画的工作。她得到这份工作了。好吧，她周围的其他家长对她接电话很不高兴。他们对她发出“嘘”声。他们说，你太粗鲁了。非常粗鲁。
Well, when you watch this, you might think their reactions kind of are harsh, right? There were a few vignettes that led up to this moment. First of all, Pam tries to get a seat in the front row. I remember this. It's in deleted scenes. And she asks the man she ends up sitting next to if he can move his son. So they put his son on his lap. He's kind of too big to sit on your lap, son.
好吧，当你看到这一幕时，你可能会觉得他们的反应有点严厉，对吧？其实有几个小片段是导致这个时刻的起因。首先，帕姆试图在前排找个座位。我记得这个。它在删减片段里。她问她最后坐在旁边的那位男士能不能把他儿子挪开。所以他们把儿子放在了他的膝盖上。儿子，坐在你的膝盖上有点太大了，儿子。
Son. To make a space for Pam. So that's the first thing she did. And then she's trying to get a better shot. and she's kind of like crawling on the floor. Like she's kind of being annoying. I remember all that. So by the time she gets the phone call, people have had it with her. Yes. Well, special guest star alert.
儿子。为了给帕姆腾出空间。所以这是她做的第一件事。然后她试图找一个更好的拍摄角度，她有点像是在地板上爬行。感觉她有点烦人。我把这些都记得清清楚楚。所以等她接到电话时，人们已经对她忍无可忍了。是的。好吧，特别客串明星警报。
The angry shushing mom and dad were played by people we know, but I'll let Kelly Cantley tell you all about it. Interesting trivia about the Ladybug Recital. Brian Whittle, our actual boom-op from multiple seasons of The Office, plays the man sitting next to Pam. And then Stephanie Lesh-Ferrell, Sean Ferrell's wife, one of our set decks, plays the woman sitting next to Brian. Also, Brian Whittle appears three times
发出愤怒“嘘”声的父母是由我们认识的人扮演的，但我会让凯利·坎特利把一切都告诉你。关于瓢虫汇演的有趣冷知识。布赖恩·惠特尔，我们《办公室》多季以来的真正收音师，扮演坐在帕姆旁边的那个男人。然后斯蒂芬妮·莱什-法雷尔，肖恩·法雷尔的妻子（我们的布景装饰之一），扮演坐在布赖恩身边的那个女人。此外，布赖恩·惠特尔出现了三次
in the credits of that episode. Brian's playing the man at the recital. Brian Whittle is also the actual boom operator credited for the show. And then Chris Diamantopoulos played Brian Whittle, the boom operator character who breaks the wall. So there's trivia. Brian Whittle, you're all over the place in this episode.
在该集的演职员表里。布赖恩饰演汇演现场的那个男人。布赖恩·惠特尔也是该剧被署名的真正的收音师。然后克里斯·迪亚曼托普洛斯饰演了打破第四堵墙的收音师角色布赖恩·惠特尔。所以这就是冷知识。布赖恩·惠特尔，你在这一集里到处都是啊。
I know. I do love that the character of the boom operator's name is Brian Whittle. First and last name. I know. Of the real guy. Of one of the real boom operators for the show. You know, this brings me to a fan question
我知道。我真的很喜欢收音师这个角色的名字叫布赖恩·惠特尔。名和姓都有。我知道。用的是真人的名字。用的是该剧真正的收音师之一的名字。你知道的，这让我想起了一个粉丝提问，
from Lindsay A. in Thousand Oaks, California, who said, my question is, why is there all of a sudden a boom operator? They've had lapel mics this whole time, and out of nowhere there's a boom operator who's been doing sound for Pam this whole time? Well, Lindsay, I think this was something that, like, we knew as actors or making a show,
来自加利福尼亚州千橡市的琳达·A，她问，我的问题是，为什么突然冒出来一个收音师？他们这一整季一直都戴着领夹麦克风，怎么突然凭空出现了一个一直为帕姆收音的收音师？好吧，琳达，我认为这是我们作为演员或制作节目的人所知道的一点，
which is that you wear a mic pack and you have a boom operator. It's very common to have both. They want to have backup sound, and so they grab sound in two different ways on projects. Always. Always. Always. Even when Josh and I do our little baking videos at home, we have a lav mic kit that we bought,
那就是你既佩戴麦克风包，又有一个收音师。两者兼备是非常普遍的。他们想要备份音频，所以在项目中他们通过两种不同的方式来收音。总是如此。总是如此。甚至当乔希和我在家里做我们的小烘焙视频时，我们也有买的领夹麦克风套装，
so we put the little mics on our shirts. But then he has one boom mic. basically he just puts on a tripod because we don't have a person to hold it, so we capture other sound. Yeah, you get the atmosphere of the room on the boom mic as well. Yeah. And a lot of times, for the most part on our show, it was the boom sound that you heard. The lav mics were back up. Yeah. But it's a really good question. Good question. Well, Dwight and Daryl bid farewell to Mr. Romanco, and Dwight asked Daryl if he's ready to tell Jim
所以我们把小麦克风别在衬衫上。但然后他有一个悬臂麦克风。基本上他只是把它放在三脚架上，因为我们没有专门的人来举着它，所以我们以此捕捉其他声音。是的，你通过悬臂麦克风也能捕捉到房间里的氛围音。是的。而且很多时候，在我们的剧中，绝大多数情况下你听到的是悬臂麦克风的声音。领夹麦克风只是备份。是的。但这真的是个好问题。好问题。好吧，德怀特和达里尔向罗曼科先生告别，德怀特问达里尔是不是准备好告诉吉姆
to go screw himself, but Daryl says, no, athlete is my future. I want to have fun at work. This gets Dwight's wheels going. Yep. Well, back in the conference room, we are still going over this Aaron Pete thing. Phyllis is on Team Pete. Yeah. Do you want to know the moment in the scene that we kept breaking and couldn't get past? Was it Kevin's line? You want me to play it for
有多远滚多远了，但达里尔说，不，运动员公司才是我的未来。我想在工作中过得开心。这让德怀特的脑子转动起来了。没错。好吧，回到会议室，我们还在继续讨论艾琳和皮特的这件事。菲莉丝是皮特战队的。是的。你们想不想知道我们在场景中不断笑场、怎么也拍不下去的那个瞬间？是凯文的那句台词吗？你想让我放给你听
you? Sure. Can everyone please stop speaking for me? Andy is my boyfriend. Pete and I are just friends. And that's the end of it, right Pete? Andy is my boyfriend. Pete and I are just friends. And that's the end of it, right Pete? That is correct. Come on guys. Where's this even coming from? Your feelings for Aaron? Probably your heart.
听吗？好啊。大家能不能别再替我说话了？安迪是我的男朋友。皮特和我只是朋友。事情就是这样，对吧，皮特？安迪是我的男朋友。皮特和我只是朋友。事情就是这样，对吧，皮特？完全正确。拜托，各位。这到底是从哪儿传出来的？你对艾琳有感觉？大概发自你的内心。
And a little bit your penis. Okay. Can't. It's also how he says penis. He doesn't say penis, he gets penis. Yes. Also, did you hear Jake's cold? He's like, come on you guys. I didn't hear it.
还有一点点发自你的命根子。好吧。不能。他连“命根子”这个词的读音都那么搞笑。他说的不是正常的发音，他念成奇怪的音。是的。另外，你们听到杰克感冒的声音了吗？他说，拜托你们了。我没听到。
Come on. I'm not hearing it. Are you kidding? Play it again. Alright, I'm going to play it again. That is correct. Come on, guys. Where's this even coming from? Come on, guys.
拜托。我没听到。你在开玩笑吧？再放一遍。好吧，我要再放一遍。完全正确。拜托，各位。这到底是从哪儿传出来的？拜托，各位。
Where's this even coming from? Where's this even coming from? I'm not hearing it. Come on. guys. Where's this even coming from? Where's this even coming from? I'm not hearing it. Come on. Are you kidding? That is correct. Come on, guys. Where's this even coming from?
这到底是从哪儿传出来的？这到底是从哪儿传出来的？我没听到。拜托。各位。这到底是从哪儿传出来的？这到底是从哪儿传出来的？我没听到。拜托。你在开玩笑吧？完全正确。拜托，各位。这到底是从哪儿传出来的？
Where's this even coming from? It doesn't sound like that to me. It does. He has a cold. I'm doing a poll. In stories, who thinks Jake had a cold? Who doesn't? Okay.
这到底是从哪儿传出来的？听起来不像是那样的啊。就是那样。他感冒了。我来做个民意调查。在故事动态里，谁觉得杰克感冒了？谁觉得没有？好吧。
Who can hear it? I can hear it. Okay. I believe you. Goodbye, you guys. I don't hear it. Where's Lizard coming from? I don't even hear it. Okay. Okay.
谁能听出来？我能听出来。好吧。我相信你。再见，各位。我听不出来。蜥蜴的声音是从哪儿来的？我根本听不出来。好吧。好吧。
Lizard doesn't hear it. Well, ultimately, the conference room scene ends and Nellie is happy because she feels like she has squashed that relationship. Yes. Back at Athlead, the team is still scrambling to keep this investor. I mean, if you're an investor and you're not interested anymore, how long do you sit around waiting for them to get a call about some information? I don't know. Also, I mean, I do get why they're scrambling. Have you looked at Athlead? That place looks expensive. It does. I agree. Pam is trying to call Jim to share this good news about the mural, but it just goes to voicemail. By the way, the investor was played by
蜥蜴听不出来。好吧，最后，会议室的场景结束了，内莉很高兴，因为她觉得自己已经成功搅黄了那段恋情。是的，在运动员公司那边，团队还在手忙脚乱地留住这个投资人。我的意思是，如果你是一个投资人，而且你不再感兴趣了，你会在那里傻等多久去听一个关于某些信息的电话？我不知道。而且，我的意思是，我确实明白他们为什么手忙脚乱。你们看过运动员公司吗？那个地方看起来真贵。确实贵。我同意。帕姆正试图给吉姆打电话分享这个关于壁画的好消息，但电话直接转到了语音信箱。顺便说一句，投资人的扮演者是
Mitch Poulos. He's been on 30 Rock most recently on Curb Your Enthusiasm and Chicago Fire, and he has played Santa more than once. Oh, yeah. Well, in the warehouse, Glen has told Daryl to jump in the delivery truck, even though he doesn't do them anymore. Well, guess what? There is another reveal in this episode, not just Brian.
米奇·普洛斯。他最近出演过《我为喜剧狂》、《抑制热情》和《芝加哥烈焰》，而且他不止一次扮演过圣诞老人。哦，是的。好吧，在仓库里，格伦让达里尔跳上送货卡车，尽管他现在已经不负责送货了。好吧，你猜怎么着？这一集里还有另一个惊喜揭晓，不只是布赖恩。
It is Dwight. He is inside the truck because now him and Daryl are gonna have fun, lady. They're gonna have fun, and they're gonna make some deliveries. They're delivering fun. This is the moment we played at the beginning of the episode. That's right.
是德怀特。他就坐在卡车里面，因为现在他和达里尔要开始找乐子了，大姐。他们要找乐子，然后要去送几趟货。他们运送的是快乐。这就是我们在本集开头播放的那个场景。没错。
And Dwight kicks it off by throwing a plastic basketball at Daryl's head. That's fun. Now he's going to pull into a fast food drive-through. Bet they don't have this in Philly. And he throws a milkshake at the employee. Yeah. Daryl is horrified.
而德怀特一上来就朝达里尔的头上扔了一个塑料篮球。这可真好玩。现在他要把车开进快餐店的汽车餐厅了。我打赌他们在费城可没有这个。然后他向员工扔了一杯奶昔。是的，达里尔吓坏了。
So horrified, he takes the keys out of the ignition. He's going to make Dwight go in and clean up the milkshake. Yeah, Dwight says this doesn't feel like a prank anymore. And while he's cleaning it all up, a couple of guys drive through and yell, fire in the hole, and throw a strawberry milkshake at Dwight. And he says, joke's on you. They make you come back and clean it up. Is this a thing? Is fire in the hole a thing? and I just think it was. Oh no isn't that terrible? That's horrible. Well I'll tell you the location of this drive-through is a very
吓得他直接把车钥匙从点火开关里拔了出来。他要让德怀特进去把奶昔清理干净。是的，德怀特说这感觉已经不像是恶作剧了。就在他清理的时候，几个家伙开车经过，大喊一声“趴下”，然后朝德怀特扔了一杯草莓奶昔。而他说，捉弄得好。他们让你回来自己打扫。这是一种流行风气吗？“趴下”这种恶作剧很流行吗？而且我觉得这就是。哦，不，这难道不是很糟糕吗？这太可怕了。好吧，我来告诉你们这个汽车餐厅的地址，它是一个非常
beloved fast food place it was just down the road from the ballet studio in Eagle Rock it's called Pete's Blue Chip Burgers. It's still there it's been there for 50 years. We closed it down while we were shooting. So all the people you see inside were all background performers that we hired to be there. The first guy who gets hit with a milkshake is Eli Vargas. He's very funny. He had a recurring role on Summerland. And the guys in the car who throw the second milkshake have an interesting connection to Steve Burgess. He shared that the teenager driving the car who throw the second milkshake have an interesting connection to Steve Burgess. He shared that the teenager driving the car was a friend of his son, Matt's, Alex McCaslin.
受喜爱的快餐店，它就在鹰岩芭蕾舞工作室的马路对面，名叫皮特蓝筹汉堡。它现在还在那儿，已经开了50年了。我们在拍摄时把它给包场了。所以你们在里面看到的所有人都是我们雇来当背景演员的。第一个被奶昔砸中的人是伊利·瓦加斯。他非常搞笑。他在《夏日之恋》中有过常驻角色。而车里扔第二个奶昔的那几个家伙和史蒂夫·伯格斯有着有趣的联系。他分享说，开车的那个扔第二个奶昔的青少年是他的儿子马特的朋，亚历克斯·麦卡斯林。
And he said his son, Matt, and Alex played soccer together since they were little kids. And when we were shooting this episode, Alex was trying to break into stunt work. So he was hired to drive. This was considered a stunt driving moment. OK. And Steve said since then, he's had a great career as a stunt performer. So Alex's dream came true.
他说他的儿子马特和亚历克斯从小一起踢足球。当我们拍摄这一集时，亚历克斯正试图涉足特技替身行业。所以他被雇来开车。这被认为是一个特技驾驶时刻。好吧。史蒂夫说从那以后，他在特技演员的道路上有了很棒的职业生涯。所以亚历克斯的梦想成真了。
Yay. Isn't that so fun? I love it. Well, we had to ask Kelly about shooting the scene, and here's what she had to say. Lots and lots of fun for me was the scene where we got to throw a milkshake at rain when Dwight gets a milkshake in the face when he's trying to clean up. That just made me laugh and then made me laugh even harder when Daryl watches it three times
太棒了。是不是很有趣？我喜欢。好吧，我们必须问问凯利关于拍摄这个场景的感受，以下是她的说法。对我来说非常有意思的一个场景是，当德怀特试图打扫时脸上被砸了一杯奶昔，我们朝雷恩扔奶昔的那场戏。这直接把我逗笑了，而当达里尔在结尾看了三遍这个视频时，我笑得更厉害了。
at the end. Did you hear it lady? Lots and lots of fun for me was shooting the scene where we throw a milkshake at Rain. I don't know. Do you think this goes back to their whole thing about like, oh yeah, like having things off your screen? Was this, I feel like maybe Kelly enjoyed that Rain got a milkshake thrown at him.
你听到了吗，大姐？对我来说非常有意思的很多事之一就是拍摄我们朝雷恩扔奶昔的场景。我不知道。你觉得这跟他们关于“哦，对，就像清理你屏幕上的东西”的那件事有关吗？这是，我觉得也许凯利很享受雷恩被扔奶昔的过程。
I think she did too. If you listen to Kelly's interview, her and Rain had a whole thing about his computer screen. Yes. I would want to throw a milkshake at him. Well, let's go back to the kitchen for a second because we have a little bit of kitchen cringe happening. Toby is going to come in and give Nellie a big old hug while she's making coffee.
我觉得她也是。如果你听凯利的采访，她和雷恩之间有一整套关于他电脑屏幕的梗。是的。我要是她，我也想朝他扔奶昔。好吧，让我们回到厨房一会儿，因为我们要经历一点厨房的尴尬场面。托比走进来，在内莉煮咖啡的时候给了她一个大大的熊抱。
And he says he's proud of how she handled the meeting. But then he says, what do you have against Pete and Erin, though? Toby reminds Nellie that Andy was terrible to Erin. Well, he doesn't say terrible. Fan mail from Destiny S in Northern Virginia says, can we please discuss Toby's comment of quote, Andy was a terrible lover to Erin.
他说他为她处理会议的方式感到骄傲。但接着他说，不过你对皮特和艾琳有什么意见？托比提醒内莉，安迪对艾琳太糟糕了。好吧，他用的词不是“糟糕”。来自弗吉尼亚州北部的粉丝命运·S发来的粉丝邮件说，我们能不能讨论一下托比的评论，原话是“安迪对艾琳来说是个糟糕的床伴”。
That's right. That's right. You're right. He said lover. Yes, that was so cringey. Destiny said, I highly dislike this word, ew. Ew. It wasn't ew.
没错。没错。你说得对。他说的是床伴。是的，太尴尬了。命运说，我极度讨厌这个词，真恶心。真恶心。才不是恶心。
You're so right. Yes. So this is a double cringe in the kitchen because I thought the hug and then when he says, you know, not everyone has what you and I have and Nellie's like, what? I thought that was cringe, but I totally forgot that he said Andy was a terrible lover. Oh my gosh. This is going to cut to a Nellie talking head where she says, Oh my goodness, I just remembered that I kissed that man.
你太对了。是的。所以这是厨房里的双重尴尬，因为我认为那个拥抱，然后当他说，你知道的，不是每个人都拥有你和我所拥有的那种关系，而内莉说，什么？我觉得这已经够尴尬了，但我完全忘了他说安迪是个糟糕的床伴。我的天哪。这直接切到了内莉的一个访谈镜头，她说，哦，我的天哪，我刚刚想起来我亲过那个男人。
There were candy bag alts for this talking head. Oh dear. Two of them I have to share. Nellie would have said, I just remembered. I kissed that guy. Apparently my brain refused to record a memory of it. And who can blame it? Poor dear. And then here is the second one and this one really cracked me up. My mouth has touched the face of sadness. I'm sorry, that made me laugh. It was like in Harry Potter when those ghosts suck your soul out of your face.
对于这个访谈，当时还有一些糖果袋替代台词。天哪。其中有两条我必须分享。内莉本来会说，我刚刚想起来。我亲过那个家伙。显然我的大脑拒绝记录关于它的任何记忆。谁又能怪它呢，可怜的亲爱的。然后这是第二条，这条真的把我笑喷了。我的嘴唇碰触过悲伤的脸庞。不好意思，这把我逗笑了。这就像《哈利·波特》里那些幽灵把你的灵魂从脸上吸走一样。
Is that hilarious? My mouth has touched the face of sadness. That is hilarious writing. Oh my goodness. Well, also back at the office, Pam asks if anyone wants to see the video from Cece's recital. Angela's like, oh, I'm swamped and holds up one piece of paper. Oscar's like, let's get this over with. I know.
是不是很搞笑？我的嘴唇碰触过悲伤的脸庞。这台词写得太搞笑了。哦，我的天哪。好吧，还有回到办公室后，帕姆问有没有人想看西西汇演的视频。安吉拉说，哦，我忙得不可开交，并举起了一张纸。奥斯卡说，赶紧把这事了结了吧。我知道。
You know, lady, this scene made me think of this moment. Years ago, I was at an Emmys party. Okay. And Isabel was a baby and everything about her was just the newest, funniest, most amazing thing and it's all I could talk about. Oh, I know what you're going to say. And I- Are you sure you don't want to save this for Office Ladies?
你知道吗，大姐，这个场景让我想起了这样一个时刻。多年前，我在一个艾美奖派对上。好吧。当时伊莎贝尔还是个婴儿，她的一切都是最新鲜、最有趣、最惊人的事情，这也是我唯一能聊的话题。哦，我知道你要说什么了。我——你确定不要把这个留到《办公室女士》节目里说吗？
Burn it to the ground. Okay, I'll save it. Oh, now you have to tell it. No, no, I'll save Okay, I'll save it. Oh, now you have to tell it. No, no, I'll save it. I'll save it. I'll save it. It's some pretty good snark and you guys will all know the people I'm talking about. People, yeah.
把它烧成灰烬吧。好吧，那我就留着。哦，现在你非说不可了。不，不，我留着——好吧，那我就留着。哦，现在你非说不可了。不，不，我留着。我留着。我留着。这可是相当精彩的吐槽，你们大家都会知道我指的是谁。大家，是的。
We'll save it. We'll save it. People Oscar'd you. People, a famous couple Oscar'd me when I was talking about my baby at an Emmys party. Now I think you have to tell it. No, I'm not going to tell it now. Don't say their names! Just say what happened. Listen to this. Listen to this.
我们留到以后说。我们留到以后说。大家，奥斯卡了你。大家，当我正在艾美奖派对上谈论我的宝宝时，有一对名人在奥斯卡我。现在我觉得你非说不可了。不，我现在不说了。别说出他们的名字！就说发生了什么。听着这个。听着这个。
Okay. We were in line, I think, for food or something. Like it was like a party and there was food. And they were in front of me, this couple, and they're famous, you guys all know them. And she was being very nice and asking me how things are. And I started telling a story about my baby because that's all I wanted to talk about was my cute, adorable baby girl. And her husband, who wasn't really making eye contact
好吧。我们当时好像是在排队买食物什么的。就像是一个派对，有吃的。他们就在我前面，这对夫妇，你们大家都认识他们。而且她人非常好，问我最近怎么样。我开始讲一个关于我宝宝的故事，因为我只想聊我可爱迷人的宝贝女儿。而她的丈夫，并没有怎么跟我进行眼神接触，
with me, kind of like looking over me for someone cooler to talk to, said to me, you know what I do when I can't fall asleep? And I was like, no. And he goes, I call my lawyer who's just had a baby and I'll say, tell me about your baby. Can you guys believe that? Can you believe that? And I was like, oh, got it.
而是越过我去看有没有什么更酷的人可以聊天，他对我说，你知道我睡不着觉的时候会做什么吗？我当时说，不知道。然后他说，我给我的律师打电话，他刚当了爸爸，然后我会说，跟我聊聊你的孩子吧。你们能相信吗？你们敢相信吗？我当时就想，哦，明白了。
I'm Aria Stark and you're now on my list. I just want to put it out there. Famous person, you know who this person is. Famous person. And you probably like him. I'll say that. Well liked, like persona. By some, I think there's a debate about him.
我是艾莉亚·史塔克，你现在上了我的死亡名单了。我只是想把它说出来。名人，你们知道这人是谁。名人。而且你们可能还挺喜欢他的。我会这么说。备受喜爱，很有公众形象。有些人吧，我觉得关于他还有点争议。
There's some douchery there, but. I will say this. What? This person, these people are not actors on the show. On our show? Yeah, they're not. Of course not. I know.
里面有点渣男行径，但是。我要说的是这个。什么？这个人，这些人不是我们剧里的演员。在我们剧里？对，他们不是。当然不是。我知道。
I just, I wouldn't want anyone to think that. We don't have that kind of douchery on our show. No. We do not. But yeah. Can you imagine? You're like in line to get some french fries and someone says that to you? I hadn't even been talking that long. It's not like I was showing videos or anything.
我只是，我可不想让任何人产生这种误解。我们剧组可没有这种渣男行径。没有。我们才没有呢。不过，真的。你能想象吗？你就像是在排队买炸薯条，然后有人对你说了那样的话？我甚至都还没说多久呢。我又不是在给别人看视频什么的。
I wasn't full Pam. Oh, excuse me! I'm so sorry! Pam wanted to show a video of her dance recital to someone since her husband wasn't there. I told one story, but I will say to call back Nora, this guy was being a full ass. Yeah. Full ass. But I will say to call back Nora this guy was being a full ass Yeah full ass My question that I've never even asked you. How did his wife respond? Was she taken aback? She just kind of did that thing where she was like, oh You know, they did not have children yet. They do now. Mm-hmm, but she kind of just said that like
我又没开启“全盘帕姆”模式。哦，不好意思！真对不起！帕姆只是想给别人看一段她女儿的舞蹈汇演视频，既然她丈夫不在的话。我只讲了一个故事，但我得说，呼应一下诺拉的话，这家伙真是一个彻头彻尾的混蛋。是的。彻头彻尾的混蛋。但我得说，呼应一下诺拉的话，这家伙真是一个彻头彻尾的混蛋。是的，彻头彻尾的混蛋。我一直没问过你的一个问题。他的妻子作何反应？她有没有感到很惊讶？她只是做出了那种反应，就是那种，哦，
Like oh they do now and they talk about them all the time. Oh. Well, maybe I'll have to go full Oscar on them. Exactly. People are going to be guessing. You know, people have been trying to guess who the musician is. The blowhard that I ran into on the hike, no one has guessed it.
你知道的，他们当时还没有孩子。现在有了。嗯，但她当时只是那样说，就像——就像，哦，他们现在有了，而且他们整天都在谈论自己的孩子。哦。好吧，也许我得对他们开启“全盘奥斯卡”模式了。没错。大家肯定都在猜。你知道的，大家一直在猜那个音乐家是谁。我在徒步时遇到的那个吹牛大王，没人猜到是谁。
I just want to say. They're never going to guess. No. It's so out of left field. It's very obscure. Famous, famous musician, but obscure. Can I give one hint to that? What?
我只想说。他们永远也猜不到。不。这太出人意料了。非常冷门。超级有名的音乐家，但很冷门。我能给个提示吗？什么？
Tall. We said that. So tall. Did we? Oh, we did. Very tall. Very tall. I'm not going to give any hints on my couple.
很高。我们说过这个了。个子非常高。我们说过吗？哦，说过。非常高。非常高。我对我的那对名人夫妇可不会给任何提示。
No. Now they have children. That's all. Except now they have children. A couple with children. No one will ever figure it out. We know. We know. And we will reveal
不。现在他们有孩子了。就这样。除了现在他们有孩子了。一对有孩子的夫妇。没人能猜得出来。我们知道。我们知道。而且我们会把
their names on office ladies' burn it to the ground. By the way, this is a very good example of a message from Angela that might begin, I have some snark. I have some snark. And now you see why we have to stop everything to listen to these messages. I know we're off topic, but if you want to stay off topic for a second, do we think that Pam's phone call was important enough to interrupt the recital? Would you have taken the call, Angela? From the city of Scranton?
他们的名字在《办公室女士：烧成灰烬》里揭晓。顺便说一句，这是一个非常好的例子，安吉拉发来的信息可能会以这句话开头：我有一些吐槽。我有一些吐槽。现在你们明白为什么我们要停下一切来听这些信息了吧。我知道我们跑题了，但如果你想继续跑题一会儿，你觉得帕姆的电话重要到足以打断汇演吗？换作是你，安吉拉，你会接这个电话吗？从斯克兰顿市政府打来的？
You're waiting to hear about your mural. They would have told me in my messages. I would have let it go to voicemail. If I'm filming the recital, the only thing I can think of is if you're so thrown that you answer by accident. And I could see... But she didn't. She answered on purpose.
你在等着听关于你壁画的消息。他们会在我的留言里告诉我。我会让它转到语音信箱。如果我在拍汇演，我能想到的唯一可能会接的情况就是你太慌乱了以至于不小心接通了。我能理解——但她可不是不小心。她是故意接的。
That's true. I really thought about this because my instinct was no, I wouldn't answer the phone in the middle of a recital unless it was some indication of an emergency. Exactly. But as an emerging artist, we get very superstitious and I could imagine having the anxiety that if I don't answer this call, they'll give it to someone else. Right, they'll think I'm unreachable
那倒是。我真的仔细想过这件事，因为我的直觉是不会，我不会在汇演中间接电话，除非有迹象表明发生了紧急情况。没错。但作为一个新晋艺术家，我们变得非常迷信，我能想象到那种焦虑感，如果我不接这个电话，他们就会把它给别人。对，他们会觉得我联系不上
and they'll pass on me. Right. Yeah. So I did understand that. Yeah, I see that. Well, Pam is trying to defend the fact that she took this phone call during the recital, but she doesn't wanna say why or who it was. So we cut to this talking head where she explains she just wants Jim
他们会原谅我的。对的。是的。所以我确实理解。是的，我懂。帕姆试图为她在独奏会上接听这个电话的事辩解，但她不想说原因或对方是谁。所以镜头切到了她的采访，她解释说她只是想让吉姆
to be the first one to know about the mural because whenever something good happens to her, he always says, Beasley! And she wants to hear a Beasley. So cute. It's very cute. So sweet. We're laying it on thick, guys. Yeah. Well, now things are just kind of awkward and miserable between Pete and Erin. He's on his way to make copies.
成为第一个知道壁画的人，因为每当她发生好事时，他总是会说：“比斯利！”她想听到一声“比斯利”。太可爱了。非常可爱。太甜了。大家，我们有点煽情过头了。是的。好吧，现在皮特和艾琳之间的气氛有点尴尬和糟糕。他正要去复印文件。
She notices. They're kind of curt to one another. And they both just look unhappy, and Nellie clocks it all. Yeah. And now Nellie is going to have a meeting with Pete and Erin. And she says, you know what? I'm going to reassemble the task force. It's my decision.
她注意到了。他们对彼此有点生硬。他们看起来都不高兴，内莉把这一切都看在眼里。是的。现在内莉要和皮特和艾琳开个会。她说，你知道吗？我要重新组建特别工作组。这是我的决定。
They have no choice. Everybody knows it. She apologizes to them. Erin and Pete are so happy. Yeah. And Toby approves. He approaches her from behind. He rubs her shoulders. He calls her lady.
他们别无选择。所有人都心知肚明。她向他们道歉。艾琳和皮特非常高兴。是的。托比也表示赞同。他从背后靠近她。他揉捏着她的肩膀。他叫她女士。
Oh, lady. Fan catch from Jessica N. in Rochester, New York said, oh, no. When Toby comes up creepily behind Nellie, he uses your our word. Lady dislike. Hums down. Yeah. And then he kind of leans in and says, you never stop surprising me. Yeah. Oh, cringe. Well here we are everyone. Oh, big reveal. Yeah. Oh, cringe. Well, here we are, everyone. Oh, big reveal. Yeah. We're going to say something.
哦，女士。来自纽约州罗切斯特市的杰西卡·N. 的粉丝留言说：“哦，不。当托比毛骨悚然地走到内莉身后时，他用了我们的那个词：‘女士’，感觉很不舒服。哼，下去了。”是的。然后他凑近一点说：“你总是能给我惊喜。”是的。哦，真尴尬。大家，我们现在在这里。哦，大揭秘。是的。我们要说点什么。
Oh, it's time. It's time. It's time. Everyone's leaving for the day and Pam gets a phone call. It's Jim. He has bad news. They lost Bridgeport capital. I do have a call sheet tidbit here. This scene was the last scene filmed on the last day on Friday. Yes. Well, Angela, there was a reason for that.
哦，时候到了。时候到了。时候到了。大家都下班离开了，帕姆接到了一个电话。是吉姆。他带来了坏消息。他们失去了布里奇波特资本公司。我这里有一条关于通告单的花絮。这场戏是周五最后一天拍的最后一场戏。是的。嗯，安吉拉，这背后是有原因的。
We wanted to clear the set and we wanted to have plenty of time to get this scene because it was complicated. Here's what's going to happen. Like I said, Jim says they lost this big client. He says he's going to have to work insanely hard for the next few weeks. Pam has a passive-ag passive aggressive comment where she says, really, I feel like you've already been working insanely hard.
我们想清空片场，并且想有充足的时间来拍这场戏，因为它很复杂。接下来会发生这些。就像我说的，吉姆说他们失去了这个大客户。他说他在接下来的几周里不得不疯狂地工作。帕姆说了一句带刺的话，她阴阳怪气地说：“真的吗？我觉得你已经一直在疯狂工作了。”
Jim says, you know what would make me feel better if I could see that video of Cece's recital? Pam tries to be lighthearted about it and is like, guess what? Turns out I'm not great with technology. I didn't get it. Jim is really upset by this. He's like, guess what, turns out I'm not great with technology, I didn't get it. Jim is really upset by this. He's like, are you kidding? I mean, come on. And Pam's like, you want to ease up a little bit? And then Jim's like, the recital is done. I missed that moment. And she's like, I'm sure another family filmed it. A lot of people were recording
吉姆说，你知道什么能让我感觉好点吗？如果我能看到茜茜独奏会的视频就好了。帕姆试图轻松地对待这件事，并说：“你猜怎么着？原来我不擅长科技产品。我没录下来。”吉姆对此非常沮丧。他说：“你开玩笑吧？拜托。”帕姆说：“你想放轻松点吗？”然后吉姆说：“独奏会已经结束了。我错过了那个时刻。”她说：“我相信其他家庭拍了。很多人都在录制
this. And he's like, oh, great. So now I can watch a recording that like focuses on their kid and we don't even get to see our kid. Now they're in it. Cause Pam says, maybe you should have been there. Yeah, if it was so important, maybe you should have been there. And he now is ticked off because he says, listen, you agreed to me spending these days in Philly. And Pam says she's trying to do her best
这个。”他说：“哦，太好了。所以现在我可以看一个只拍了他们孩子的录像，而我们甚至看不到自己的孩子。”现在他们吵起来了。因为帕姆说：“也许你应该去现场。”是的，如果它那么重要，也许你应该去现场。他现在被激怒了，因为他说：“听着，你同意我在费城度过这些日子。”帕姆说她正在尽最大努力
to make things perfect so he can do what he wants to do. Basically, he's like, oh, this is what I want to do? You think I'm just doing this for myself? Because if so, then this is a very sad night. Now, Jim is being called back to work and he's like, you know what, I got to go. I'll talk to you tomorrow. Yeah. She's like, fine, talk to you tomorrow. Pam starts to break down and this is how it was written in the shooting draft.
把事情做到完美，这样他就能做他想做的事。基本上，他就像是：“哦，这就是我想做的事？你以为我这么做只是为了我自己吗？因为如果是这样，那这将是一个非常悲伤的夜晚。”现在，吉姆被叫回工作岗位，他说：“你知道吗，我得走了。我明天再跟你谈。”是的。她说：“好吧，明天见。”帕姆开始崩溃，剧本初稿里是这样写的：
Pam hangs up upset. She looks around and realizes she is the only one left at work. She slumps and then unexpectedly starts to cry. We watch her cry for a little. Then she turns tear-stained face to the side of the room and says, Brian, what am I doing wrong? What did I do? There's a beat. Pam looks like she really needs an answer. Brian Whittle responds, nothing.
帕姆挂断电话，感到很难过。她环顾四周，意识到自己是办公室里唯一留下来的人。她无力地垮下肩膀，然后出乎意料地哭了起来。我们看着她哭了一会儿。接着，她把挂满泪水的脸转向房间的一侧，说道：“布莱恩，我到底在做什么？我做了什么？”停顿了一下。帕姆看起来真的很需要一个答案。布莱恩·惠特尔回答说：“什么也没做。
You're doing the best you can. The camera frame quivers a moment of indecision, and then the operator pulls wide to see that Pam is talking to the boom operator, Brian. He looks sympathetic. Fan question from Chloe B in Australia. During the phone call between Pam and Jim, Pam is super upset. I was wondering if Jim really was on the other end of the phone during this scene.
你已经尽力了。”摄像机镜头微微颤动，带着一丝犹豫，接着摄影师将镜头拉宽，发现帕姆正在和麦克风收音员布莱恩说话。他看起来很同情她。来自澳大利亚克洛伊·B 的粉丝提问。在帕姆和吉姆的电话期间，帕姆非常难过。我想知道这场戏期间吉姆是否真的在电话的另一端。
Yes, Chloe. Our sound engineer Ben hooked it up so that we could actually talk to each other in the two offices. I was on the main stage and the athlete set was over in our warehouse building. But setting this up was a huge ordeal, but it was also super important. But I'll let Kelly Cantley, our director, tell you a little more about it.
是的，克洛伊。我们的音响工程师本搭建了设备，让我们实际上可以在两个办公室里互相通话。我在主舞台，而运动员布景在我们的仓库大楼里。但设置这个东西是一项巨大的工程，不过它也非常重要。但我会让我们的导演凯利·坎特利向你们多介绍一点。
The phone call was so stressful. There was so much going on. So normally in television, when we shoot a phone call, we shoot each actor individually. So you would shoot one on Tuesday and one on Friday and if you're lucky the person off camera is actually off camera to give you your cue lines. But on the office we did as much live as we could so anytime we had a FaceTime we would have a little set over on a corner of the stage and we'd have an actual live FaceTime.
那个电话非常紧张。有太多事情在发生。通常在电视制作中，当我们拍摄电话通话时，我们会分别拍摄每个演员。所以你会在周二拍一个，在周五拍一个，如果你幸运的话，镜头外的那个演员真的在镜头外给你念台词。但在《办公室》中，我们尽可能地进行现场实拍，所以每当我们有 FaceTime 戏份时，我们会在舞台的角落搭一个小布景，并进行真实的实时 FaceTime通话。
We tried to do it with phone calls as much as we could. And in this case, because the argument was such an important story point and arguments are sort of better when two people are arguing, we worked out a way to shoot John playing Jim on the other stage in the athletes set. And then Pam, Jenna, was on our regular set. And there were some technical hoops to jump through to make it happen. I was on set with Jenna, and Stephanie Kinch, one of the assistant directors, was on set with John. I could see John through the monitor and listen to the dialogue on the com text and then in between takes I could talk to him on the phone.
我们尽可能通过电话来完成。在这种情况下，因为这场争论是一个非常重要的故事节点，而且两个人吵架时争论的效果会更好，所以我们想出了一种方法，让约翰在运动员布景的另一个舞台上扮演吉姆。然后帕姆，也就是珍娜，在我们的常规布景里。要实现这一点，需要克服一些技术障碍。我和珍娜在片场，而助理导演之一的斯蒂芬妮·金奇和约翰在片场。我可以通过监视器看到约翰，并通过对讲系统听台词，然后在拍摄间隙我可以在电话里跟他说话。
Jenna, I don't know if you remember this, but also on set with us, it was you, the crew, me and every producer or executive who'd ever been involved in the office was there. Angela, it was not just every producer. It was like every writer. Like there were so many people. Greg was there. So many people invested in us getting this moment right. It was a lot of pressure.
珍娜，我不知道你是否还记得，当时和我们一起在片场的，除了你、剧组、我之外，还有所有曾参与过《办公室》的制片人或高管。安吉拉，不只是每个制片人。就像所有的编剧都在。有好多人。格雷格也在。有这么多人投入其中，希望我们能把这个时刻拍对。压力太大了。
John was insulated from it a little bit. You were surrounded by it. I was surrounded by it. Yes, because our video village was on lot of pressure. John was insulated from it a little bit. You were surrounded by it. I was surrounded by it. Yes, because our video village was on the main stage. Yes. We got a fan question from Courtney B in Perth, Western Australia, who said, I would love to know how you got into character
约翰受到的这方面的干扰比较少一点。你被包围在其中。我被包围在其中。是的，因为我们的视频监看区在主舞台。是的。我们收到了来自西澳大利亚州珀斯的科特妮·B 的粉丝提问，她说：“我很想知道你是如何进入角色
for such an emotional scene. Well, Courtney, this scene really hinged on me being able to break down crying. And I'll tell you that in many ways, the writing and the words and the planning of these emotional beats were enough to get me nearly there. Just playing the truth of the scene to be Pam and having this disconnect from Jim, her true love,
来演绎这样一场充满情绪的戏的。”嗯，科特妮，这场戏真的关键在于我能不能情绪崩溃大哭。我得说，在很多方面，剧本、台词以及对这些情感转折的规划已经足以让我差不多进入状态了。只要顺着戏的真实情境去演，去当帕姆，并与吉姆——她的真爱——产生这种隔阂，
that is like devastating. And so that got me nearly there. But they really needed me to have tears streaming down my face. That's hard to do. So what we did was we did a take where John, as Jim in character, laid into me really hard. It was dialogue that we agreed we would never use,
这就像是毁灭性的打击。所以这让我差不多进入了状态。但他们真的需要我做到热泪盈眶。这很难做到。所以我们做的是，我们拍了一条，约翰作为吉姆入戏，对我进行了非常严厉的指责。这是我们事先商量好绝不会采用的台词，
and they didn't even run the camera on his side. But through the phone, I just said, you need to get really upset with Pam. And I'll react as Pam. Yeah. You know, and John was a little nervous about it because he said, this is gonna be out of character for Jim, so we can't use it. But I will do this for you, Jenna. I'll help you. And I was like, I really appreciate it. So we turned the camera off on his side and it was just him on the phone. So there was that take that you see in the episode that was,
而且他们甚至没有开他那边的摄像机。但通过电话，我只是说：“你需要对帕姆非常生气。我会以帕姆的身份做出反应。”是的。你知道的，约翰对此有点紧张，因为他说：“这会不符合吉姆的人设，所以我们不能用。但我会为你这么做的，珍娜。我会帮你的。”我说：“我真的很感激。”所以我们关掉了他那边的摄像机，电话里只有他。所以在剧集里看到的那个镜头是，
he like really laid into Pam and I just it was water works and you just reacted yeah as Pam so I got there with with his help yeah I mean sometimes you know in scenes as your scene partner you do that for each other mm-hmm and even sometimes they'll be a director that will give you a note that just breaks your heart open. Yep, that's right. And you kind of need it in the moment. And then I think a lot of times you get yourself there, but then if you need to dial it up or dial it down,
他狠狠地数落了帕姆一通，然后我——这就成了泪闸，你只是作为帕姆做出了反应，是的。所以我在他的帮助下进入了状态，是的。我的意思是，有时你知道，在戏里作为你的对手演员，你们会为彼此这样做，嗯。甚至有时会有一个导演给你一句直击心灵深处的提示。是的，没错。你当时确实需要它。然后我认为很多时候是你自己进入状态，但如果你需要把情绪加强或减弱，
it's really nice to have a scene partner that can help you dial it up emotionally. Well, that was the thing. We had gotten a number of takes, but we were gonna go one more time. And I said, okay, for this final one, let her really sob, but I need help. Yeah.
能有一个能在情感上帮你加强的对手演员真的很好。嗯，就是这样。我们已经拍了很多条，但我们还要再拍一次。我说：“好吧，为了最后这一条，让她尽情痛哭吧，但我需要帮助。”是的。
And speaking of that, the first part of this was just getting the fight right. And then the second part was getting this big reveal right. Mm-hmm. Yeah, Kelly shared with us about how much planning and discussion went into shooting all of this, and also about the different shots that she needed to get. So not only did she need to make sure all this emotion was happening,
说到这个，这的第一部分是把吵架拍好。第二部分是把这个大揭秘拍好。嗯。是的，凯利跟我们分享了拍摄这一切花费了多少筹划和讨论，以及她需要拍摄的不同镜头。所以她不仅要确保所有这些情绪都在到位，
but technically she had to make sure she covered it right. Here's what she had to say. Matt and I had come up with a plan for how to block it so that it would be kind of easy to get the camera to Chris, who played Brian the boom up when he breaks the fourth wall. And then when we rehearsed it, Greg had pictured it very differently. So we put everybody in those positions and we rehearsed again and we started to shoot and there were lots of opinions on how to shoot it. And we started shooting it like he was a character. And we did five or six takes.
而且在技术上她必须确保镜头涵盖得当。以下是她的说法：“我和马特想好了一个分镜计划，这样当扮演布姆（Boom）的克里斯打破第四堵墙时，摄像机很容易拍到他。然后当我们排练时，格雷格的设想完全不同。所以我们把每个人都安排在那些位置上，我们重新排练并开始拍摄，对于怎么拍有很多不同的意见。我们开始把他当成一个角色来拍。我们拍了五六条。”
And Greg said, okay, I think I have what I need. And I said, well, I think I'd like to go one more time. And he was like, okay, great, get what you need. Jenna, I came in to talk to you and you looked up and you're hysterically crying because we just kind of, you said, I have one more take and then I'm done. I was like, oh my God, I felt really bad for asking you to do it again. But we really needed one more take and then I'm done. I was like, oh my God, I felt really bad for asking you to do it again.
格雷格说，好吧，我想我有我需要的了。我说，嗯，我想我愿意再拍一次。他说，好吧，太棒了，去拍你需要的。珍娜，我进来找你，你抬起头，歇斯底里地哭着，因为我们刚刚，你说，我再拍一条就结束了。当时我想，噢天哪，我为让你再拍一次感到非常抱歉。但我们真的需要再拍一条就结束了。当时我想，噢天哪，我为让你再拍一次感到非常抱歉。
But we really needed one more because the argument was great and it ramped up to the point where it was super believable the way two people who love each other can just like go at each other. The fight was great. Your reaction was great. It was heartbreaking. The only thing that really bugged me is that we were shooting Chris like a character.
但我们真的需要再拍一条，因为这场争吵太棒了，它层层递进，两个相爱的人互相攻击的方式显得极其真实可信。这场争吵很棒。你的反应很棒。这太让人心碎了。唯一真正让我困扰的是，我们把克里斯拍得像个角色。
And I thought that we needed to shoot it like it was found footage. Like the doc, you know, they didn't know they were going to show this as part of the doc when it happened. So I had had an idea because whenever something like disturbing happened or somebody made a noise, a wreck to take, or if a camera person had to give a note, they would like shift the camera sort of at a cocked angle on their shoulder to make it more comfortable, give the note or tell the person whatever, and then put the camera back up and be ready to go. So I ran in, apologized to you for going again, and said to Matt Sohn, Matt, this time, as soon as Chris talks,
我觉得我们需要把它拍得像找到的素材（伪纪录片风格）。就像纪录片一样，你知道，事情发生时他们并不知道会把这个作为纪录片的一部分播出来。所以当时我有个想法，因为每当发生什么令人不安的事情，或者有人发出噪音、需要重拍，或者摄影师需要给出意见时，他们会把摄像机放在肩膀上以一个倾斜的角度偏转，让自己更舒服一些，然后给出意见或告诉对方什么，接着再把摄像机放回肩上准备好。所以我跑进来，为再次拍摄向你道歉，并对马特·索恩说，马特，这次，只要克里斯一说话，
cock this camera onto your shoulder like you're gonna yell at me for something and turn to him and say his name or something, like hey, cut it out, so that it's found. And then once he's in there, you can just cover it because that's what you would do. So we all agree what we're doing and we go again. cut it out so that it's found. And then once he's in there, you can just cover it because that's what you would do. So we all agree what we're doing and we go again.
就把摄像机扛到你的肩膀上，就像你要因为什么事对我大喊大叫一样，然后转向他，叫他的名字什么的，比如‘嘿，住手’，这样它看起来就是无意中拍到的。然后一旦他介入了，你就可以把它挡住，因为这就是你会做的。所以我们都同意了我们要做的，然后我们再次开拍。住手，这样它看起来就是无意中拍到的。然后一旦他介入了，你就可以把它挡住，因为这就是你会做的。所以我们都同意了我们要做的，然后我们再次开拍。
And I realize once I say action and the scene is going and it's really good, and then I think, oh my gosh, I forgot to give him a note about the end. So I did the worst thing that you can ever do as a director or an assistant director. I grabbed my ADs radio, Rusty Mamoud, and I turned to the camera channel, and on the very last line, where Chris plays Brian, says, that's enough, I say, Matt, tell it to the floor.
我意识到当我喊‘Action’并且场景正在进行而且真的很棒时，然后我想，噢天哪，我忘了给他关于结尾的提示。所以我做了作为导演或副导演所能做的最糟糕的事情。我抓起副导演的对讲机，拉斯特·马穆德，我调到了摄像机频道，在最后一句台词上，克里斯饰演的布莱恩说，‘够了’，我说，‘马特，把镜头摇到地面。’
So that we're on the floor and you can hear the last line, and then you're just out. So that was very stressful, but I thought the scene came out really good, and I thought, Jenna, that you and John did such a good job with the acting of it. And Chris was great as the boom-up. So that was a really long clip, but I think so fascinating to see how she set that up.
这样我们就拍到地面，你能听到最后一句台词，然后就切出去了。所以这非常令人紧张，但我认为这个场景出来效果非常好，珍娜，我觉得你和约翰在表演上做得太棒了。而克里斯作为收音师也很棒。所以这是一个很长的片段，但我认为看到她是如何布置这一切的非常迷人。
But there were a couple things that she said that stood out to me. For example, you know, at the end of every take, I'm crying, but now I have to uncry and go back to the beginning. And that's the exhausting part, is like taking that journey over and over and over again. So she was so sweet to be kind of looking out for me.
但她说的有几点让我印象深刻。例如，你知道，每次拍摄结束时，我都在哭，但现在我必须停止哭泣并回到开头。这就是最累人的地方，就是一遍又一遍地经历那种心路历程。所以她真的很贴心，一直在照顾我。
But then also her brilliant idea to have the camera shift. Come off the shoulder. Yes, which is what our camera operators did all the time on set. Yeah, the minute we stopped filming, they would take it off their shoulder. Or if something happened. Yes, so, so smart.
还有她绝妙的主意，让摄像机偏移。从肩膀上拿下来。是的，这正是我们的摄像师在片场经常做的事情。是的，我们一停止拍摄，他们就会把它从肩膀上拿下来。或者如果有什么事情发生。是的，太，太聪明了。
So the boom operator was played by Chris Diamantopoulos. At some point, I'm going to share all about him and his casting session for this role, but I wanted to wait until after the reveal. Okay. So, Brian the Boom Guy is gonna be with us for a little while. I'll tell you all about Chris and how he stole this role. You know, obviously, I don't ever wanna see you cry,
所以收音师由克里斯·迪亚曼托普洛斯饰演。在某个时候，我要分享关于他以及他为这个角色的选角试镜的所有事情，但我一直想等到剧集揭晓之后。好的。所以，布莱恩·麦克风男将和我们在一起一段时间。我会把关于克里斯以及他是如何赢得这个角色的事都告诉你。你知道，显然，我绝不想看到你哭，
but in watching this and rewatching it, at least you look cute when you cry. Don't take me wrong. When I cry and rewatching it, at least you look cute when you cry. Don't take me wrong. When I cry and I really like cry, it is the ugly cry. Like it is a hot mess. And you still look cute. Well, thank you. I mean, this wasn't an ugly cry.
但在看这个和重看这个时，至少你哭的时候看起来很可爱。别误会我。当我哭并且重看时，至少你哭的时候看起来很可爱。别误会我。当我哭的时候，我是真的在哭，那是丑陋的哭。就像是一团糟。而你看起来依然很可爱。嗯，谢谢你。我的意思是，这不是那种丑陋的哭。
I can do an ugly cry for you. But this was like, ugh, this was just, I don't know what. Just- Heartbroken. Desperate at the end of my rope. And sad. Yeah, deeply sad. Deeply sad.
我可以为你展示一次丑陋的哭。但这次就像是，呃，这只是，我不知道是什么。只是——心碎。绝望，走投无路。还有悲伤。是的，深深的悲伤。深深的悲伤。
Yeah. Well, this episode's gonna end on an up. We've got a tag, Dwight's Day of Fun. Maybe, I don't know, it did work out because Darryl's having a good time watching an online video of Dwight's Day of Fun. Maybe, I don't know, it did work out because Darrell's having a good time watching an online video of Dwight being hit with a milkshake. Yeah, it's already uploaded, it's posted to the internet,
是的。好吧，这一集将以一个积极的基调结束。我们有一个彩蛋，德怀特的欢乐日。也许，我不知道，结果确实挺好，因为达里尔在津津有味地看一个关于德怀特欢乐日的在线视频。也许，我不知道，结果确实挺好，因为达里尔在津津有味地看一个关于德怀特被奶昔砸中的在线视频。是的，它已经上传了，发布到互联网上了，
and he hits it on repeat, and he laughs. Yeah, he says, maybe I am gonna miss the paper business. Well, I bet no one's gonna take him on a ride adventure for fun over at Athlead. They seem kind of serious. Not like this one. Yeah.
他把它设置为循环播放，然后大笑。是的，他说，也许我真的会想念造纸业。嗯，我敢打赌在Athlead那边没人会带他去进行刺激的冒险当做消遣。他们看起来挺严肃的。不像这个。是的。
Well, listen, before we go, we just wanted to give you Kelly's final thoughts on directing this episode. She has some really nice things to say. The other thing I should share is that the cast and crew were amazing to me when I directed. I had directed the mentor webisodes and this was my first episode and everybody was wonderful. The cast was great. Jenna you were awesome. Angela you were great. Everybody was really nice to me. The crew went over and above to help me do a great job. Matt Zone, our DP operator, and Sarah Levy, our other camera operator, amazing.
好了，听着，在我们离开之前，我们只想让大家听听凯莉对导演这一集的最后感想。她有一些非常好的话要说。另外我应该分享的是，当我执导时，演员和剧组对我太棒了。我执导过导师网络剧，这是我的第一集，每个人都很好。演员阵容很棒。珍娜你太棒了。安吉拉你太棒了。每个人对我真的都很好。剧组付出了加倍的努力来帮我做好工作。我们的DP操作员马特·佐恩，以及我们的另一位摄像师莎拉·利维，都太棒了。
They had great ideas and they're amazing operators. And Rusty Mahmood, my AD, did a great job for me. He was super supportive. So it was a really good experience for me. Oh, I'm so glad that Kelly mentioned Sarah. Sarah Levy, one of our real camera operators, is who is operating the camera in the reveal moment as well. Yes. She's standing right next to Brian, the boom, quote-unquote, operator.
他们有很棒的想法，而且是非常优秀的摄像师。我的副导演拉斯特·马穆德为我做了出色的工作。他非常支持我。所以对我来说这是一次非常好的经历。噢，我很高兴凯莉提到了莎拉。莎拉·利维，我们真正的摄像师之一，也是在揭晓时刻操作摄像机的人。是的。她就站在布莱恩，那个所谓的收音师旁边。
Yes. And that's how it works, by the way. Each camera gets a boom operator. They're like a little pair. They go around together. Well, that was customer loyalty. Thank you so much Steve Burgess for all of your behind the scenes information. And thank you Kelly Cantley for those awesome audio clips. We loved hearing about your time directing this episode. And thank you to my daughter Isabel for sharing with us about being a ladybug in this episode. She loves office ladies. She was so tickled when I asked
是的。顺便说一下，事情就是这样运作的。每个摄像机都有一个收音师。他们就像是一对小搭档。他们总是一起四处走动。好了，这就是客户忠诚度。非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯提供所有幕后信息。也感谢凯莉·坎特利带来那些精彩的音频剪辑。我们非常喜欢听你讲述执导这一集的时光。还要感谢我的女儿伊abelle，与我们分享她在这一集中扮演瓢虫的经历。她非常喜欢办公室女郎。当我问她时，她高兴极了
her to be on the podcast. She was like, tickled when I asked her to be on the podcast. She was like, seriously, Mom? I get to be on the podcast? She had to be on the podcast. I know. She's a guest star. And I do have to tell you one thing. She was like, Mom, can I hear what I sound like? And when I played it back for her, she goes, oh my gosh, that's what I sound like. That's what everybody says when they hear their voice. I know. But thank you, Isabelle. I loved rewatching this episode with you.
她能上播客。她当时说，当我邀请她上播客时，她兴奋极了。她就像是，真的吗，妈妈？我能上播客吗？她必须上播客。我知道。她是个特邀嘉宾。我确实得告诉你一件事。她当时说，妈妈，我听起来是什么声音？当我把录音放给她听时，她惊呼，噢天哪，这就是我听起来的声音啊。每个人听到自己的声音时都会这么说。我知道。但谢谢你，伊莎贝尔。我很开心能和你一起重看这一集。
Well, thank you to all of you for writing in. We hope we helped you get some things off your chest today. There was a lot of mail. There really was. There's going to be more. Oh, and before we go, we want to give a big shout out to our pal, Rainn Wilson. He has his new podcast. Yes, it's called Soul Boom the Podcast.
好吧，谢谢所有写信给我们的朋友。希望我们今天帮你们卸下了一些心事。有很多来信。确实有很多。以后还会有更多。哦，在我们离开之前，我们要向我们的老朋友雷恩·威尔逊大声致敬。他有了他的新播客。是的，它叫做心灵繁荣播客。
You remember we had Rain on to talk about his book, Soul Boom, Why We Need a Spiritual Revolution. Well, this podcast is going to cover similar themes. Yes, and I'm a guest on his show. I was a little nervous, but it was wonderful to sit down with Rain. We talked about some real big life moments that shaped our lives. I laughed a little nervous, but it was wonderful to sit down with Rain. We talked about some real big life moments that shaped our lives. I laughed a lot. I cried.
还记得我们请雷恩来谈论他的书《心灵繁荣：为什么我们需要一场精神革命》吗？嗯，这个播客将涵盖类似的主题。是的，我是他节目的嘉宾。我有点紧张，但和雷恩坐在一起聊天感觉太棒了。我们聊了一些塑造了我们人生的重大时刻。我笑了笑，虽然有点紧张，但和雷恩坐在一起聊天感觉太棒了。我们聊了一些塑造了我们人生的重大时刻。我笑了好多。我哭了。
He's such a thoughtful person, and I'm really looking forward to his new podcast. I think it's just going to be great. You guys, he does film his podcast, just so you know. And I showed up with barely any makeup on because I don't wear a lot of makeup out and about, you know? I think also if memory serves, you didn't know that he filmed his podcast? On the way, pretty much the day of,
他是一个非常体贴的人，我真的很期待他的新播客。我觉得它一定会非常棒。伙计们，他录制了他的播客，顺便告诉你们一下。我出现时几乎没化什么妆，因为我出门在外不怎么化妆，你知道吗？我想如果我没记错的话，你当时不知道他录制了他的播客？在路上，差不多就在当天，
Rain was like, oh, Ange, we're gonna film it. And I was like, oh, and you know, I am not judged. It is just real life, two folks talking. Anyone who decides to watch the podcast rather than listen to it, no need to be snarky. I look how I look. I'm 53 and I'm real happy in my own skin. And I'm so thankful to be turning 53 this year. And what a blessing it is to grow old. So I hope you enjoy it. It's a great podcast. Enjoy looking at my old wrinkly ass. Who's happy to be here.
雷恩说，哦，安吉，我们要把它拍下来。我说，哦，你知道的，我不会被评判。这只是真实的生活，两个人在聊天。任何决定观看播客而不是收听播客的人，没必要冷嘲热讽。我长什么样就是什么样。我53岁了，我对现在的自己非常满意。我很感激今年能迎来53岁生日。变老是多么大的福气啊。所以我希望你们喜欢它。这是一个很棒的播客。尽情欣赏我这张老而满是皱纹的屁股吧。一个很高兴来到这里的人。
Oh Angela, I am gonna toot our horns. Oh toot them. Because I just turned 50 and I declare that the decade of tooting your own horn and giving zero Fs. Yes. So here I go. I admire deeply how you and I have embraced our age. Thank you, lady. I think so too. We have embraced our changing bodies, our changing faces, our changing hormones, all of it. And that doesn't mean we don't complain about it.
哦，安吉拉，我要为我们自己吹吹牛。哦，吹吧。因为我刚刚50岁，我宣布这是为自己吹牛且完全不在乎别人看法的十年。是的。所以我要开始了。我深深地钦佩你和我如何拥抱我们的年龄。谢谢你，女士。我也这么觉得。我们拥抱了我们不断变化的身体，我们不断变化的脸庞，我们不断变化的荷尔蒙，这一切。这并不意味着我们不会对此发牢骚。
It doesn't mean that we don't like certain angles. That's true. Doesn't mean that we don't throw a filter on it. And let me tell you, there's some unflattering angles when you do a podcast that's filmed. So enjoy those. But it's a wonderful podcast. I'm really happy for Rain. Next time Rain let me know in advance that it's filmed.
并不意味着我们不喜欢某些角度。确实如此。并不意味着我们不会给它加个滤镜。我得告诉你们，当你做一档有视频拍摄的播客时，有些角度真的很不讨巧。所以尽情享受那些画面吧。但这是一个非常棒的播客。我真的为雷恩感到高兴。下次雷恩提前告诉我这是要拍摄的。
Maybe I'll pay for hair and makeup. Everyone, please go check out Soul Boom the Podcast with Rainn Wilson. It's out now wherever you get your podcasts. And of course, Angela will put a swipe up in our stories. Absolutely. All right, we hope you have a good one. Take care. We'll see you next week.
也许我会花钱做个头发和化妆。大家，请去看看雷恩·威尔逊主持的心灵繁荣播客。现在各大播客平台都可以收看了。当然，安吉拉会在我们的动态里放一个上滑链接。绝对的。好了，希望你们过得愉快。保重。我们下周见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听办公室女郎。办公室女郎由Earwulf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。